bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public scénat retour ce matin sur la
discussion générale du projet loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
l'examen de ce texte a débuté hier au
Sénat et cela s'apparente un marathon
budgétaire particulièrement compliqué
pour le gouvernement il faut dire que la
droite risque d'unir ses voix avec celle
des communistes pour rejeter ce texte
hier les ministres qui sont intervenu en
séance nont en effet pas donné suite à
la principale revendication des
sénateurs communistes qui demandent
l'abrogation de la taxe sur les retraite
qui a déjà été votée par l'Assemblée
nationale et qui est destiné à financer
la dépendance si le Sénat rejette
mercredi soir la première partie
concernant les recettes de ce projet de
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale et bien c'est tout l'ensemble du
texte qui tombera dé facto ce matin donc
retour sur la discussion générale bonne
séance à
tous nous reprenons donc la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'Assemblée nationale de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2013 et dans la
suite de la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Jean
Desessard bravo c'est la santé
hein
bien monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers
collègues au début de l'examen du projet
de loi il y a une idée forte qui était
sans C se répéter une idée forte
maintenant on dit plus ça je crois on
dit un élément de langage donc il y
avait un élément de langage qui revenait
très souvent impératif de redress
des comptes sociaux sans que cela ne
soit effectué au détriment de la santé
des Français alors cétait tellement
répété que je suis dit uno ou un
tox bien sûr bien sûr je partage nous
partageons cette finalité de répondre au
besoins présents et futur de nos
concitoyens mais cela relevail de la
méthode cé qu'ionnous proposé de
différent comment allions-nous Pier au
au Maronniers annuel comme diraientent
les journalistes du déficit chronique de
la sécurité social et aux envolet
lyriques sur notre incapacité à faire
face mais j'ai été rassuré à la lecture
du projet je dois reconnaître madame la
ministre une certaine
satisfaction dans la suite logique du
projet de loi de finance rectificative
pour 2012 adopté cet été l' ACC est mis
sur la participation de chacun en
fonction de ses moyens sur la mise à
contribution de forme de revenu jusque-l
peut voire pas sollicité afin de ne pas
une nouvelle fois privilégier des
remboursements et autres taxations sur
les consultations
médicales augmentation de la tax de la
taxe sur les stocks option pour les
entreprises et les bénéficiaires ou
encore augmentation du taux du forfait
social sont de bonnes mesures
elle dissuade les entreprises de verser
de trop fortes rémunérations
complémentaires comme cell dont on parle
souvent depuis 2008 à savoir les bonus
des tradur d'autres formes de
contribution sont à trouver de même que
d'autres exceptions au nich sociales
sont à minorer parmi les pistes je pense
bien sûr à celle défendu par ma collègue
madame Aline archembour pour taxer des
produits dont l'abus est nocif pour la
santé faire évoluer les comportements et
permettre des actions de prévention
ces actions apparaissent pour certains
comme des coûts supplémentaires au
lancement mais à terme viennent diminuer
les coûts de prise en charge des
maladies auquel ces produits concour
rappelons comme le souligne la
communication de la Commission des
finances que la progression des besoins
de soins résulte notamment d'un nombre
croissant de patients soignés pour des
pathologies lourdes ou chroniques à
savoir par exemple les cancers c'est un
peu comme notre problème économique et
écologique les investissements dans la
transition écologique peuvent apparaître
comme du luxe comme un luxe en temps de
crise alors même qu'ils sont une réponse
à celle-ci bref il s'agit en matière de
santé comme ailleurs d'anticiper
d'anticiper mais pas trop tard je sais
mes collègues je vous entends vous dites
mais nous sommes tous écologistes et oui
mais il y a les écologistes
d'aujourd'hui pour agir tout de suite pu
il y a ceux qui reportent à demain plus
tard on verra
bien ceci est d'autant plus nécessaire
quand on sait que les hypothèses de
réduction des déficits du PLFSS se
fondent sur des hypothèses de croissance
et d'augmentation de la masse salariale
pour 2013 et jusqu'à 2017 largement
sujette à caution cela ceci étant
dit absolument ceci mais on va essayer
de faire mentir les chiffres chers
collègues ceci étant dit je n'irai pas
plus loin
sur ces considérations d'ordre général
sur les recettes voyons côté dépenses à
quoi a-t-on décidé de les affecter
quelle priorité et vision de la société
peut-on lire dans les orientations
prises madame marchambau et moi-même
nous sommes répartis l'examen des quatre
branches madame archambau a
pris la santé accident au travail moi
vieillesse et famille je pouvais être
content il y avait pas grandchose à en
dire mais est-ce qu'on peut être
satisfait là ce qu'il y a moins de
sujets à traiter hein ce n n'est pas
vraiment une satisfaction le moindre
développement de ces deux partis traduit
vieess et famille un léger malaise celui
de ne pas encore pouvoir accorder toute
l'atention à ces postes que ces postes
exigent commençons par la branche vis
j'ai inclurit la question des retraites
et des contributions nouvellement
demandées au retraités vous comprendrez
aisément pourquoi nous avons abordé dans
cette émicycle il y a une quinzaine de
jour la proposition de loi de Monsieur
roche visant à élargir la contribution
de solidarité pour l'autonomie au
travailleurs non salariés et au
retraités et à compenser ainsi au
département la moitié de leurs dépenses
d'allocation personnalisée d'autonomie
lors de mon intervention j'avais
insister sur la caducité de cette
proposition eu égard à l'article 16 du
présent projet de loi la contribution
des retraités a beaucoup été décrié lors
de l'examen à l'Assemblée ici même et
dans la rue beaucoup nous ont interpellé
pourtant aujourd'hui la moyenne en
moyenne les personnes âgées bénéficent
bénéficient d'un niveau veau de vie
proche de celui des actifs et la mesure
ne touche pas les petites retraites mais
bien sûr cela ne se sait pas assez alors
il ne s'agit pas de nier les difficultés
rencontrées par nombre des retraités
pensons notamment au retraités agricoes
dont les pensions restent plus faibles
que la moyenne et qui doivent justifier
d'un seuil d'années de cotisation qu'on
exige pas des autres professions pour
pouvoir accéder à leurs droits et ce
àors même que leurs horaires
ont largement dépassé 35 heur et et que
la convergence de leur niveau de vie
avec celui des autres actifs un des
objectifs de la Politique Agricole
Commune est loin d'être acquise mon
collègue Joel Labé fera d'ailleurs des
propositions à ce sujet pour tener
compte de cette réalité du spectre
important de la situation des retraités
je défendrai un amendement de notre
groupe pour introduire une progressivité
dans le montant de la contribution de
solidarité mesure qui nous apparaît plus
juste et qui devrait également inspirer
la CSG à ce sujet toujours de la
diversité des situations de retraité
j'aimerais rappeler celle des personnes
en fin de parcours professionnel qui ne
trouve pas d'emploi ont acquit
suffisamment de trimestre mais n'ont pas
atteint l'âge légal de la retraite
l'abandon de la loocation équivalent
retraite au 1er janvier 2011 n'a été que
partiellement comblé par la mise en
place de la location transitoire de
solidarité l'examen prochain du PF
permettra je l'espère d'en reparler j'en
viens maintenant à la branche famille
les propositions ici sont peu nombreuses
plusieurs membres du conseil
d'administration de la Caisse nationale
des allocation familiales l'ont regretté
et la CAF a donné un avis défvorable au
projet de loi ceci s'explique
semble-t-il essentiellement par le
décalage du calendrier la conférence
sociale nous ayant promis d'avancer vers
une meilleure adéquation des dispositifs
aux besoins des familles à cet égard
l'article 71 qui permet d'étendre les
expérimentation de tir payant mené par
le Conseil Général de lesesson est
intéressant puisqu'il Perm aux familles
à revenu modestes de ne pas faire
l'avance des frais pour la garde de
leurs enfants nous proposerons
d'ailleurs des amendements visant à
s'assurer que les conditions seront
réunis pour réussir ces expérimentations
notamment sur les territoires en tension
où les offres de garde sont
insuffisante c'est de toutes ces
questions qu'il conviendra de discuter
lors de l'étude du projet présent projet
si cela nous est permis aussi bien au
volet recettes qu'au volet dépenses
j'espère que nous pourrons parler mes
chers collègues en
conclusion j'aimerais ouvrir quelques
pistes de réflexion nous essayons autant
que possible de traduire dans ce projet
de loi une certaine vision de la société
c'est le sens que j'évoquais par exemple
des proposition de nouvelles recettes au
travers de la taxation de produits dont
l'ABU participe à une dégradation de
l'état de santé mais pour bon nombre de
nos concitoyens cette séquence du PLFSS
peut apparaître peu
compréhensible peut-être parce que trop
comptable trop bataille d'apothicaaire
mais nous sommes dans le sujet nous
devrions donc nous astreindre à un
effort de lisibilité et peut-être pour
cela envisager à terme l'examen de ce
type de projet à la lumière
d'indicateurs sensibles de notre société
comme l'indice de santé sociale mesurer
en fonction des âges de la vie si les
besoins fondamentaux sont satisfaits et
bien en fonction des âges de la vie pour
sortir des oppositions retraité actives
jeunes pour rejeter les corpor
qui conduis à monter les gens contre les
les uns contre les autres sur le
fantasme de privilège supposé le P
PLFSS doit traduire une vision de vivre
ensemble doit unifier pour construire un
projet de vie commun et j'aurai un mot à
mes
collègues des bans de gauche les ban de
gauche sont larg maintenant mais un ban
plus à
gauche
chers collègues il y a une mutation la
société
aujourd'hui on n plus comme au lendemain
de la guerre
et le monde du travail a changé la place
du travail a changé dans la vie on fait
pas toujours la même chose et on est
bien obligé d'envisager les cotisations
sur autre chos que la masse salariale on
est bien obligé de tenir compte de la
santé environnementale on doit bien
envisager cette mutation économique et
donc vous avez raison l ce qu'il faut
dire faut pas tout abandonner il faut
pas mais il faut quand même réfléchir à
la nouvelle au nouveau contrat social
nous devons lors du PLFSS et c'est là
madame la ministre que je souhaite qu'il
y ait une vision d'avenir nous devons
lors du projain
PLFSS retrouver le nouveau Pact de la
sécurité sociale le nouveau Pact de la
santé sociale le nouveau contrat de
solidarité sociale pour tenir compte de
cette mutation écologique donc oui au
aujourd'hui nous votons ce PLFSS mais
nous sommes attentifs à un projet de
solidarité sociale qui tienent compte et
bien de la mutation économique la
mutation sociale la mutation écologique
de notre
sociétéerci merci Monsieur Desessard la
parole est à Monsieur Philippe B pour le
groupe
um
monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
présidente monsieur le rapporteur et
chers
collègues en débattant du projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité
sociale le Parlement exerce chaque année
une prérogative
essentielle que la Constitution ne lui
connait d'ailleurs que depuis 16
ans comme chaque année je ne peux
m'empêcher de penser avec une certaine
reconnaissance au président Chirac à
Alain Jupé à Jacques barraot qui prire
l'initiative de ce progrès majeur des
droits du
Parlement il nous appartient d'être à la
hauteur de cette grande ambition qui
consiste à ce que le Parlement prennent
ses responsabilités pour permettre à la
solidarité nationale de s'exercer
pleinement tout en veillant à
sauvegarder les équilibres financiers
dont dépend l'avenir de la protection
sociale nous savons bien en effet qu'il
n'est pas de solidarité durable si elle
est financée à crédit ou alimenté par un
excès de prélèvement sur l'activité et
sur l'emploi c'est à cette haône que les
mérites d'un projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale se
mesure et j'avoue que je ne suis guerre
convaincu par la manière madame la
ministre dont vous avez tenté de relever
une première fois ce
défi je veux revenir en premier lieu sur
la trajectoire sur laquelle vous
inscrivez nos comptes sociaux pour les 4
années à venir en insistant sur la
question des 7 les montants et les taux
d'évolution que vous avez retenu pour
2013 et au-delà de 2013 ne relève pas de
prévision réaliste cela vient d'être dit
vos engagements resteront un vœ pieux
s'ils ne sont pas prolongés par un
vigoureux effort de redressement conduit
avec détermination dans la durée et
portant d'abord sur les dépenses
or malgré l'optimisme dont témoignent
vos objectifs ou plutôt vos
espérances vous osez encore prévoir le
maintien d'un déficit de 10 milliards
d'euros en 2017 c'est à l'évidence un
résultat un objectif insuffisant au
terme d'une si longue
période mais de sur croix c'est hélas un
objectif que vous ne vous donnez même
pas les moyens
d'atteindre ni d'ailleurs d'atteindre
par les bons moyens certes les
hypothèses de croissance ressemblent par
nature au bulletin
météorologique relativement fiable pour
le futur immédiat elles sont aléatoires
à plus de 4 ou 6 mois une chose paraît
claire cependant si on se réfère au
consensus des économistes c'est que les
mois à venir seront plus proches de la
stagnation voire de la récession que du
taux pourtant médiocre de 08 % sur
lequel vous avez fondé vos budgets pour
2013 l'impact négatif de cette
conjoncture pour les recettes de la
sécurité sociale est déjà fort il va
encore s'aggraver ce qui nous inquiète
profondément et devrait vous inquiéter
aussi vous avez massivement augmenté les
prélèvements depuis juillet dernier 7
milliards d'euros dans le collectif 20
milliards en loi de finance initiale et
maintenant près de 5 milliards de
recettes supplémentaires en loi de
financement de la sécurité
sociale cette politique ne peut donner
les mêmes résultats en terme de
réduction des déficits qu'une politique
de maîtrise renforcée de la dépense car
elle apauvrit les Français et leurs
entreprises aggravant une crise
qui diminue déjà les rentrées fiscales
et
sociales c'est une solution de facilité
la hausse brutal et massive des
prélèvements plutôt que le freinage
puissant des dépenses par des réformes
structurelles et par une jection
exigence exigeante
pardon je reviendrai dans un instant sur
certaines des hausses de prélèvement
proposé pour dem
2013 cependant avant même que cette loi
de financement été AD
le Premier ministre vient de rendre
caduc l'engagement figurant dans
l'annexe B du projet de ne pas prendre
de nouvelles mesures de recette après
l'année 2013 il a en effet décidé une
importante réforme du financement de la
sécurité sociale dont les principes
sinon les modalités semblent d'ailleurs
analogues à ceux de la réforme que nous
avions adopté en février dernier et que
vous aviez décidé en toute hâte
d'abroger dès juillet les Français ont
le tourni ils veulent qu'un cap soit
donné et qu'il soit tenu il est normal
que vous corrigiez le plus vite possible
vos erreurs mais la politique financière
et sociale de la France demande de la
constance c'est la condition pour créer
la confiance des consommateurs des
épargnants des opérateurs économiques de
nos partenaires européens et aussi des
marchés car ceci existe et nous avons
besoin d'eux pour financer notre dette
au moindre coût hors de la constance
justement vous n'en avez pas soit dit en
passant quitte à regretter vos V et
viens
successif je préfère que l'évolution de
votre réflexion se fasse dans notre sens
avec la recherche d'un allègement du
coût du travail plutôt qu'en sens
contraire
comme au début du
quinena il reste que nous ne pouvons
plus nous prononcer sur cette loi de
financement seulement en fonction de ce
qu'elle contient mais aussi en fonction
de ce qu'elle ne contient pas qui en
transformera l'économie générale et
l'interprétation
j'admets
qu'une réforme structurelle du
financement de la sécurité sociale ne
puisse produire son plein effet à court
terme mais justement si vous voulez
qu'elle soit utile à moyen
terme en allégeant fortement le coût du
travail et en faisant contribuer nos
importations il faut que la réforme soit
mise en vre dans toute son ampleur dès
son entrée en vigueur et cela le plusôt
possible puisque ce n'est pas votre
intention l'impact que nous pourrions en
attendre pour la croissance et l'emploi
sera malheureusement dilué et tardif
nous n'avons pas tant d'atout face à la
crise actuelle que nous puissions nous
permettre de les gâcher les prélèvements
c'est maintenant les baisses de
cotisation c'est peut-être et plus tard
et ce n'est sûrement pas le bon choix le
système de crédit d'impôt ou plutôt de
crédit de cotisation que vous avez
l'intention de mettre en place soulevera
de très sérieuses difficultés de mise en
œuvre qui en diminueront l'efficacité et
surtout il a pour conséquence de
différer d'un an encore le bénéfice de
la réforme pour les
entreprises alors même que la
progressivité de celle-ci qui vient
s'ajouter j'ai le regret de le dire à
vos atermoim de l'année 2012 la rend
déjà peu incitative et je le
regrette il y a pourtant urgence les
comptes sont mauvais la conjoncture est
à tonne le chômage 7 an ainsi que les
dépenses de RSA et d'allocation de
logement répondre à cette situation par
des mesures cosmétiques dont on attend
le plein effet seulement à compter de
l'achèvement d'une montée en régime de 4
ans s'agissant par ailleurs des mesures
de recette que comporte dès maintenant
votre projet mon sentiment est que vous
avez vidé les fonds de tiroir des
administrations il en résulte un
véritable brique à
brac vous avez tort vous avez vraiment
tort de pénaliser les
entreprises qui procèdent à la rupture
conventionnelle du contrat de travail
car c'est le salarié qui en réalité sera
pénalisé cela ne cesse de contredire le
sentiment de l'équité dont vous avez
l'habitude de vous
prévaloir ces indemnités ne sont pas un
revenu mais compensation à la rupture du
contrat de travail une forme de
réparation au moment où un travailleur
s'apprête à faire l'expérience du
parcours du combattant de la recherche
d'emploi l'application du forfait social
de 20 % non pas pour les indemnités les
plus importantes mais dès le premier
euro d'indemnité constitue pour
l'entreprise une charge que rien ne
justifie elle transforme la nature de
ces indemnités elle aura une incidence
négative sur leur montant c'est un coup
de canif dans le contrat sur lequel
repose le développement remarquable du
système de la rupture conventionnelle si
votre intention est de lui donner un
coup d'arrêt autant le dire franchement
et l'assumer clairement devant le monde
du
travail quant au prélèvement de 0,3 %
que vous créz sur une partie importante
des pensions de retraite il est autement
contestable il est destiné au
financement d'une réforme de la prise à
charge de la dépendance que vous aurez
du mal à faire aboutir rapidement dans
la conjoncture actuelle tandis que la
taxe elle
restera dans l'attente dans l'attente de
cette réforme son produit n'est pas
directement affecté au financement de
l'APA qui en aurait pourtant bien besoin
enfin on ne peut qu'être surpris de
constater que la recette de 2013 sera
verser au fond de solidarité vieillesse
pour diminuer la participation de l'État
à ce fond sans venir le moins du monde
soulager les personnes dépendantes au
nom desquelles vous faites ce
prélèvement cela relève d'une forme
d'imposture vis-à-vis des retraités ils
ne peuvent être contraint de contribuer
ainsi sans rien recevoir en échange que
des promesses pour plus
tard et que dire et que dire du sort que
vous réservez au travailleurs
indépendants vous l'apparence de bonnes
intentions rendre proportionnel le
prélèvement social alors qu'il est
aujourd'hui dégressif à cause du plafond
qui s'applique au revenus pris en compte
mais la réalité de la mesure proposée
est tout autre il s'agit de prélever dès
2013 plus d'un milliard d'euros sur le
monde artisanal sous couvert de justice
c'est une mauvaise action au moment où
vous sembliez vous intéresser enfin à la
compétitivité de nos entreprises vous
oubliez sans doute que les artisans sont
aujourd'hui les premiers employeurs de
France alors je pourrais m'apesantir
aussi sur les dépenses pour la maladie
c'est un relâchement cert léger de
l'effort la Cour des comptes l'a
critiqué à juste titre sur les retraites
c'est le silence un silence profond
alors que nous savons que les réformes
successives de 1993 2003 et 2010 doivent
être prolongé et se poursuivre je
regrette à cet égard que les conclusions
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
ne soient connu que le mois prochain
quand nous aurons terminé
d'examiner ce projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale
qu'allez-vous faire pour prolonger la
réforme des retraites nous n'aurons pas
de réponse cette année et je crains car
nous avons l'expérience du gouvernement
qu'élas vous ne preniez pas à bras le
corp ces difficultés qui continuent à
préoccuper les Français la réforme doit
être permanente elle doit se poursuivre
nous ne comptons pas sur vous pour le
faire alors mes chers collègues madame
la ministre tels sont les principales
raisons pour lesquelles nous ne voterons
pas ce projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale je vous vous
l'annonce cela semble vous surprendre ce
n'est pas que ces ambitions nous
paraissent trop élevées c'est au
contraire que leur modestie l'absence de
lignes directrices pour une politique de
sécurité sociale soucieuse de
sauvegarder notre modèle en l'adaptant
les changements de pied incessants
auxquels vous soumettz les Français
l'addition des prélèvements
supplémentaires qui résulte de chaque
nouveau texte présenté au Parlement
depuis 6 mois votre silence sur l'avenir
des retraites le peu de gage que vous
donner de votre volonté de mettre en
œuvre fermement la maîtrise médicalisée
des dépenses de santé en particulier à
l'hôpital font craindre que les
objectifs que vous présentez ne puissent
être atteints sans nouveau prélèvement
cette politique qui n'en est pas une
conduit à une impasse nous ne pouvons
donc pas
l'approuver merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Michelle meunier
pour le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président Madame
la ministre monsieur le rapporteur
général chers collègues l'exercice
auquel nous sommes soumis dans le cadre
de ce PLF SS 2013 est difficile car très
contraint les marges de manœuvre
financière sont serrées mais l'enjeu est
bel et bien de définir une politique
plus juste gageons qu'il s'agisse là
d'un plan de finances intermédiaire qui
assaignira progressivement la situation
économique grevée par les erreurs et les
déficits accumulés par les gouvernements
intérieur de
droite qu'on se le dise contrairement à
ce qu'a dit mon prédécesseur c'est en
tout cas un PLFSS responsable et
solidaire malgré tout ce plan 2013
accompagne de grandes orientations
sociale visant par exemple à assurer une
retraite digne pour nos concitoyennes et
nos concitoyens visant à un égal accès
aux soins une meilleure protection des
salariés et un soutien renforcé aux
familles modestes en ce qui concerne la
branche famille ce sont 600 millions
d'euros supplémentaires qui ont été
crédités pour limiter l'ampleur du
déficit à
2700000 € au lieu de 3 millions
milliards pardon milliards 2 millions de
2 Milard 700000 € au lieu des 3 Millard
300000 prévu et ce n'est pas rien des
mesures nouvelles sont proposé par le
gouvernement malgré ce contexte tendu
afin de soutenir les familles notamment
les plus exposées à la crise tout
d'abord le gouvernement propose une
méthode et des objectifs pour adapter
l'offre en matière d'accueil de la
petite enfance la ministre madame
Dominique bercinotti a engagé une
concertation avec avec l'ensemble des
parties prenantes notamment les parents
mais aussi les professionnels les élus
sur quatre régions françaises
métropolitaines il s'agit de mieux
appréhender les besoins des familles de
faire connaître les bonnes pratiques
locales afin ensuite de définir les axes
prioritaires qui seront intégrés au
contrat d'objectif et de gestion qui
sera conclu entre l'État et la CNAF pour
2013 à 2016 cette méthode est
prometteuse car il existe de fortes
diversités sur les territoires tant en
terme de qualité des réponses proposées
que de places disponibles puisqu'on
compte des écarts allant de 26 à 76
places d'accueil pour 100 enfants selon
les territoires il s'agit là à
l'occasion de ces concertations locales
de s'appuyer sur les expériences
concrètes qui pourront être analysées
voire généraliser et cette méthode est
la bonne elle a fait ses preuves les
objectifs ne sont pas seulement
quantitatifs mais aussi qualitatifs car
augmenter le nombre global de places
d'accueil ne suffit pas il faut adapter
l'offre au plus au plus près des lieux
de vie des familles et combiner les
réponses les plus souvent il faut aussi
poursuivre la professionnalisation des
personnels en charge de la petite
enfance ces réponses doivent se
construire avec l'ensemble des acteurs
locaux impliqués l'état joura en lien
avec la NAF les collectivités et les
familles son rôle stratégique de cadrage
de la politique globale en matière
d'accueil de la petite enfance et
garantira un accès équitable à ses
services sur l'ensemble du territoire
national agir ainsi c'est permettre aux
parents d'exercer une activité
professionnelle c'est aussi concourir à
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
sur le plan professionnelle et dans la
prise en charge des responsabilités
familiales parallèlement ce PLF FSS 2013
vient en aide aux familles modestes
confrontées à des difficultés pour
financer l'accueil de leurs enfants
jusqu'àors les familles doivent faire
l'avance des frais de garde pour
l'assistante maternelle ou pour la garde
à domicile en attendant le remboursement
de l'aide de la CAF à terme échu il est
proposé ici de mettre en place à titre
expérimental pour 2 ans un système de
tiers payant pour les ménages ayant des
ressources inférieures au montant du RSA
dans un premier temps l'aide de la CF
sera alors versé directement à la
salariée de la famille qui s'acquittera
du sol de la de la rémunération auprès
d'elle cette mesure va être
particulièrement appréciée des familles
qui confient leur enfants à une
assistante maternelle notamment en
milieu rural où ce mode d'accueil est le
plus fréquent nous en tirerons bien sûr
le bilan avant sa généralisation voilà
une méthode qui mérite aussi de devenir
plus systématique afin d'innover dans le
secteur social expérimenter grandeur
nature et alu analyser avant de
généraliser le cas échéant une autre
mesure est proposée suite aux travaux de
l'Assemblée nationale en faveur des
familles surendettées en risque
d'expulsion de leur logement il s'agit
de permettre leur rétablissement
automatique de toutes les allocations
logement à l'instar de l'APL dès lors
qu'un dossier de surendettement est jugé
recevable le rétablissement de ces
droits devrait permettre à ces ménages
une sortie plus rapide de l'ornière
financière dans laquelle elle se trouvve
mais une politique en faveur des
familles ne se résume pas aux mesures
inscrites à la branche famille du PLFSS
chaque budget doit pouvoir supporter la
part relative aux actions en faveur des
enfants des jeunes et des familles
relevant de ces responsabilités c'est
ainsi que le Fond national de la
protection de l'enfance prévu pour
soutenir la politique de protection de
l'enfance assurée par les conseils
généraux ne peut-être abondé uniquement
par le budget de la Sécurité sociale en
effet les départements font face à la
prise en charge des mineurs isolés
étrangers qui impactent leur budget
alors même que ce jeune public relève
principalement des politiques liées à
l'entrée sur le territoire je me réjouis
d'ailleurs des discussions qui se sont
enfin engagées entre l'assemblée
départementale de France et les les
ministères concernés afin de trouver des
solutions adaptées à la prise en charge
de ces jeunes et tenables pour les
départements une politique en faveur des
familles ne se réduit pas non plus à une
politique nataliste c'est un engagement
global qui mise fortement sur sa
jeunesse et sur son avenir elle se doit
de prendre en compte les familles dans
toute leur diversité de composition de
lieux d'habitation de parcours de vie de
niveau de revenu d'origine culturelle
d'état de santé elles doivent pouvoir
trouver des réponses adaptées à leurs
besoins tout au long de leur vie et sans
discrimination toutes les mesures votées
ou actuellement en discussion qui visent
à rechercher l'égalité entre les
familles et entre les femmes et les
hommes sont autant de jalons qui
construisent l'environnement familial et
sociétal pour notre jeunesse car tout se
tient augmenter laallocation de rentrée
scolaire de 25 % soit peu plus de 70 €
par enfant pour les 3 millions de
familles les plus modestes qui en ont
bénéficié est un signe fort elle a
concerné dans une large majorité des
familles monoparentales dont les maères
sont à la tête de la famille dans 85 %
des cas de même se reposer la question
de la scolarisation en maternel dès 2
ans constitue un axe fort d'une
politique familiale plus juste par
ailleurs ce PLFSS 2013 propose de
corriger une inéquité flagrante à
l'égard des familles homoparentales
d'ailleurs signalé par la Haute autorité
de lutte contre les discriminations il
sera discuté un amendement poursuivant
les travaux de l'Assemblée national
visant à créer un congé de paternité et
d'accueil à l'enfant pour permettre
ainsi au compagnon ou à la compagne de
la mère qui sera présente lors de
l'arrivée de l'enfant de bénéficier de
ce congé rémunéré de plein droit
l'ensemble de ces mesures d'aide aux
familles joue incontestablement un rôle
de redistribution particulièrement en
temps de crise les collectivités locales
notamment via les CCAS viennent les
compléter soutenu aussi par le milieu
associatif pour les familles rencontront
d'importantes difficultés il nous faudra
résolument pour sivre nos efforts pour
que les familles les plus modestes
soient davantage aidé comme l'a
d'ailleurs souligné la rapporteur
Isabelle Pasquet je pense notamment aux
familles monoparentales les plus
exposées financièrement et le rapport
annuel du Secours Catholique publié la
semaine dernière le montre bien mieux
vaut aider précocément plutôt de que de
compenser par des mesures de protection
de l'enfance très coûteuses
financièrement mais aussi socialement
ensuite je pense aussi au congés de
maternité auquels des femmes on situ
situation de précarité face à leur
emploi sont exclus car n'ayant pas
suffisamment de droit d'accès aux
indemnités journalières sur mon
département de la Loire Atlantique la
CAF et la CPAM estiment qu'elle serait
au moins 10 % en 2011 il nous faut
revoir cette question dans le sens d'une
plus grande équité nous devons repenser
notre système d'aide aux familles afin
de renforcer ses fonction redistributive
et de réduction des inégalités comme le
préconise d'ailleurs la Cour des comptes
dans son rapport pour 2012 une mise à
placeat s'impose pour redonner une
cohérence d'ensemble aux différentes
aides la Cour des comptes insiste sur la
nécessité de revoir l'économie
d'ensemble des prestations familiales
sous conditions et modulé en fonction
des ressources des ménages en renforçant
d'une part l'aide aux familles
vulnérables et d'autre part en réformant
la prestation d'accueil aux jeunes
enfants et ciblant plus étroitement les
familles bénéficiaires je sous
tout à fait à ces préconisations qui
vont dans le sens d'une plus grande
justice redistributive car les familles
nous attendent je vous remercie merci ma
chère collègue la parole est à Madame
Laurence Cohen pour le groupe
CRC monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègue le système
hospitalier public français constitue un
atout majeur au service de la qualité
des soins dispensés au population
l'excellence de la médecine qui y est
pratiqué la force de son maillage
territorial bien que mise à mal par les
précédent gouvernement la disponibilité
des équipes médicales et paramédicales
le haut niveau de formation qu'il permet
de dispenser aux internes l'application
des tarifs opposables l'accueil de tous
les patients sans distinction de
pathologie et d'origine voici en quelque
sorte l'ADN des hôpitaux publics et je
pense madame la ministre que nous sommes
d'accord pour convenir que ce sont
autant de différences avec le service
privé lucratif vous avez annoncé
l'adoption prochaine d'un projet de loi
contenant une disposition symbolique la
réintroduction dans le code de la santé
publique de la notion de service public
hospitalier cela nous apparît d'autant
plus important que Nicolas Sarkozi et
son gouvernement avait avec la loi HPST
notamment que d'ailleurs nous
souhaiterions voir abroger il avait donc
entrepris une œuvre de destruction du
service public hospitalier transformant
l'hôpital en entreprise de soins et
réduisant la démocratie en son sein ça
ne vous plaît pas mais c'est la réalité
en confiant de plus en plus de missions
de service public aux structures
commerciales en permettant l'émergence
de groupements de coopération sanitaire
alliant établissement public et lucratif
il a tenté de faire croire qu'au final
il n'y avait plus de différence entre
les hôpitaux et les cliniques privées ce
faisant il a oublié une réalité les
dépassements d'honoraires dans les
structures publiques sont l'exception
quand les tarifs prohibitif dans les
cliniques sont légion nous attendons
donc avec impatience cette loi cette
volonté d'assimilation du public et du
privée n'est pas récente et
l'instauration de la convergence
tarifaire entre les hôpitaux et les
cliniques y on ont participé et
participe pleinement vouloir comparer
puis aligner les prix des établissements
publics de santé sur ceux des cliniqu
privé c'est mé cononnaître leurs
différen fondamentales mentionné au
début de mon propos les soins non
programmés coûtent incstestablement bien
plus cher que les soins programmés les
fragilités sanitaires et sociales des
publics soignés dans les hôpitaux sont
évidemment bien plus important que pour
les patients qui peuvent financièrement
opter pour les soins dans des cliniques
commerciales le gel de cette convergence
contre nature est donc heureux or si
elle limite les dégâts elle ne revient
pas sur les erreurs du passé et les
tarifs qui ont déjà fait l'objet de
cette convergence ne sont
malheureusement pas revus cela nous
apparaît pourtant particulièrement
nécessaire tout tout comme il nous
apparaît nécessaire de doter les
établissements public de santé des
moyens financiers dont ils ont besoin or
l'évolution du taux de long d'â fixé
cette année à 2,6 % pour les hôpitaux
nous semble insuffisant il faudrait au
moins le porter à 3 % ne serait-ce que
pour permettre aux hôpitaux de faire
face aux dépenses contraintes liées par
exemple à l'amélioration des
rémunérations ou encore à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie ou des dépenses
propres aux hôpitaux d'après les
estimations de la Fédération
hospitalière de France cette année
encore l'effort financier exigés des
établissements publics de santé serait
de 650 millions soit peu de chose près
le montant exigé en 2012 chaque
établissement aujourd'hui rogne sur le
matériel médical la maintenance jusqu'à
celle des ascenseurs cet effort
financier a eu également pour effet la
suppression de 8000 postes aggravant les
mauvaises conditions de travail des
personnels et réduisant de fait la
qualité des soins dispensés aux patients
les propos des salariés de la PHP le
plus important CHU d'Europe que j'ai
auditionné la semaine dernière sont tout
à fait et alarmant témoignant d'une
réelle souffrance au travail avec une
montée du nombre des suicides dont on ne
parle pas les mêmes causes produisant
les mêmes effets nous sommes inquiets
c'est d'ailleurs la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons qu'un moratoire soit mis
en œuvre sur la fermeture des
établissements public de santé et sur
les regroupements de leurs services on
nous oppose l'argument de sécurité mais
les hôpitaux de proximité tout comme les
cliniques d'ailleurs constittuent
parfois la seule structure de soins vers
laquelle les patients peuvent s'orienter
comment justifier par exemple que pour
des raisons de sécurité on impose aux
femmes enceintes de faire à la
Guadeloupe plus d'une heure de bateau
pour se rendre au CHU de Pointe à Pitre
est-ce véritablement plus sûr que
d'accoucher à la maternité de Marie
Galante nous ne le croyons pas vous
souhaitez à juste titre madame la
ministre établir un PCT de confiance à
l'hôpital ce que nous soutenons à
condition qu'il institue une vraie
démocratie sanitaire avec un pouvoir
redonné au personnel à leur syndicats
aux patients et aux élus et mettre fin à
la toutepuissance des directeurs des ARS
bien entendu les mesures que nous
proposons exigent la réalisation d'un
préalable sortir du paiement à l'acte et
mieux prendre en compte les missions de
service public la commission d'ailleurs
des affaires sociales du Sénat a émis un
rapport fort intéressant allant en ce
sens enfin et ne pouvant intervenir plus
longuement je voudrais dire notre
inquiétude face à la proposition que
vous formulez dans ce PLFSS d'autoriser
les hôpitaux à émettre des billets de
trésorerie en lieu et place de cette
mesure nous aurions pour notre part
préféré que la Caisse des dépôts et des
de consignation puisse être autorisée à
proposer des prêts à taux zéro aux
hôpitaux l'insuffisance de long d'ARM
l'autorisation d'émettre des billets de
trésorerie la mesure adoptée à votre
initiative concernant la biologie
hospitalière et la hausse de la taxe sur
les salaires nous paraissent être des
mesures peu compatibles avec votre
objectif de renforcement du service
public hospitalier le groupe CRC n'y
souscrit pas Raon pour laquelle nous
nous exprimons sur chacune nous nous
exprimerons sur chacune des mesures
concernant l'hôpital au cas par cas et
nous espérons que les choses évolueront
dans le bon sens merci merci ma chère
collègue la parole est à Monsieur Serge
d'assau pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre madame la présidente monsieur
le rapporteur chers collègues je neis
pas vous faire la critique de vos
propositions budgétaires d'autres l'ont
déjà fait et le feront vis simplement
vous faire quelques
remarques d'abord que le déficit de nos
installations
hospitalière il faut le reconnaître est
dû aux grandes parties au
35hur voilà que vous ne voulez pas
comprendre et qui sont la conséquence de
l'augmentation de personnel et du
déficit il faut bien que quelqu'un paye
et quand on travaille pas et ben ça paye
plus cher que quand on travaille que le
budget est indépendant du budget de
l'État le budget qui est de la sécurité
sociale mais qu'il y a qu'un seul
financeur c'est le contribuable et que
ce contribuable a ou aura à sa charge
les deux budgets celui de l'État et
celui de la sécurité sociale et que le
déficit de la sécurité sociale ne
s'ajoute pas pour le moment au déficit
du budget de la loi de finance mais est
soigneusement rangé dans un organisme
appelé la cadesse qu amortissement de la
dette sociale où les déficits accumulés
sont financés par des emprunts qui
s'ajoutent en réalité à ce duet de
l'État pour atteindre 1800 milliards au
sens de M pour la fin 2012 c'est ce
qu'on appelle publiquement des dépenses
hors budget mais au moment où chacun
essaye de réduire les charges sur les
salaires de façon substantielle sans y
arriver vis vous soumettre à tous une
solution écoutez bien ce n'est pas
facile écoutez bien je vous propose de
réduire ces charges sur salaire de 55 %
sans aucune augmentation d'impôt ni de
TVA tout en financement en finançant
totalement le budget de la Sécurité
sociale y compris son
déficit cette opération facilitera en
outre les embauches les augmentations de
salairire tout en réduisant les coûts de
production et faciliter les ventes je
vous rappelle que les chares sur salaire
des entreprises sont de deux ordres
d'abord les charges directement au
salariés retraite chômage accident de
travail ensuite C lié à la maladie à la
famille la la CG qui dépend du
gouvernement je vous propose de
dissocier totalement ces deux
dépenses ce système ne s'appliquant
qu'aux entreprise marchande en 2009
c'est les chiffres à retenir toutes les
charges sur salaire ont représenté
393 milliards d'euros
dont retraite chômage et action du
travail 176 milliards celle de la
maladie la famille avec la CG Cardis 217
milliards hors
déficit je vous propose de ne garder
comme charge sur les salaires que les
176 milliards qui concernent les
entreprises
chmage retraite accident du travail
celles concernant les les entreprises on
les réduira donc de 50 % au lieu de
payer
393 milliards les entreprises payeront
comme charge au salaire 176 milliards
donc réduction de 55
%. remarqué et aussi que ces charges
seront toutes patronnales si bien que
désormais tous les salaires seront des
salaires nets avec 45 % de charge cette
opération facilitera les embuches qui
coûteront moins cher les augmentations
de salaire qui coûteront moins cher et
réduira les coûts de production qui
coûteront moins cher et facile les
ventes le reste me direz-vous on les
paye comment les 217 milliards ça va
venir ces 217 milliards seront payés par
les entreprises
elles-mêmes sous forme de frais générau
comme les loyers comme le DF et cetera à
l'aide d'une formule qui favorisera les
entreprises de main d'œuvre donc le
travail ayant de nombreux salariés et
les entreprises de œuvre ayant de
nombreux salariés payeront moins de
charges on répartira les charges entre
ceux qui utilisent la m d'œuvre il
payeront moins et ceux les entreprises
de service qui font un gros chiffre
d'affaires avec peu de personnel qui
payeront
plus ainsi que les entreprises qui
délocalisent ou qui ont du personnel
étranger parce que dans la formule de
réduction il n'y a que le personnel
français le personnel étranger n'étant
pas pris en compte par la formule
salaire chiffre d'affaires moins
salarial et donc le total pour ces
entreprises sera plus élevé elles
payeront plus de charg donc cela
défavorisera les entreprises qui
délocalisent les entreprises qui
impimportent pour
cela pour cela il faudra mettre en place
ce que j'appelle un coefficient
d'activité couvrant toutes les
entreprises marchandes chaque entreprise
calculant ses charges en multipliant ce
coefficient par son chiffre d'affair
moins la masse salariale c'est là
qu'intervient cette astuce qui fait que
plus il y a de masse salariale moins on
paye et moins il y a masse salariale
plus on paye ce qui favorise l'activité
et la réduction du chômage et je vous
signale je vous donne pas la formule
complète ser compliqué mais je vous la
donner plus tard ASI avec un
coefficient qui a été calculé de
6,6 on obtiendra un total de 217
milliards c'est-à-dire le total de ce
que coûte aujourd'hui la part qui est
payé par pour la sécurité sociale la
part pour le travail étant à part ainsi
avec ce coefficient 66 on 917 milliards
mais l'intérêt de l'opération est aussi
que vous pourrez y intégrer le déficit
de la Sécurité sociale c'est-à-dire au
lieu de dire que vous aurez une dépense
de 217 milliards supposons que la Sécur
sociale fasse un milliard de déficit
vous ferez le calcul avec 227 avec 237
milliards ou moins si le déficit est
moins élevé ce qui fait que cela
rapportera à l'état 20 milliards de plus
et cela réduira le déficit budgétaire
donc l'intérêt de cette opération en
plus est que vous pourrez intégrer le
défic de social quel qu'il soit en
ajoutant le chiffre nécessaire et en
faisant le calcul on s'aperçoit ce qui
est très important sur le plan financier
qu' augmentant de 06 points ce
coefficient d'activité cela rapporte 20
milliards à l'État c'est-à-dire que
c'est une sorte de TVA qui qui n'en est
pas une mais qui rapporte beaucoup parce
qu'elle a une large assiette et un petit
tau donc en passant de 66 à 72 avec ce
coefficient d'activité on obtient 20
milliards de plus et on équilibre le
budget la social quel qu'il soit voilà
madame le ministre que je voulais vous
proposer baisser de 55 % les charges sur
salaire quand même intéressant sans que
ça coûte un sous à l'état et sans TVA
sociale ou autre c'est fini ça sert à
rien on n parle plus et équilibrer le la
cécu sociale le tout sans augmentation
d'impôts les charges des entreprises de
main d'œuvre sera moins élevé celle
entreprises services sont plus élevé
sans aucune connaissance pour le budget
de l'État et les impôts le chômage
pourra diminuer plus
d'embauche la croissance reprendra avec
une augmentation du pouvoir d'achat par
augmentation des salaires qui ne
coûteront que 55 % de charges au lieu de
100 % voilà je trouve madame la ministre
que ça vait la peine de vous la
proposer je présenterai une proposition
de loi à ce sujet que c'est un peu
compliqué mais j'espère que vous la
défendrez Madame le Ministre merci chers
collègu merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Samia Gall pour le
groupe socialiste
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers
collègues le présent rapport de loi de
finan de scurité sociale traduit la
priorité que constitue le secteur
médico-social pour le gouvernement
malgré un contexte budgétaire
difficile ainsi avec une progression de
l'objectif national des dépenses
l'assurance maladie médico-sociale de 4
% 650 millions d'euros de mesures
nouvelles seront consacrées à la prise
en charge des personnes âgées et des
personnes en situation
d'handicap cette décision traduit dans
les faits et les les engagements pris
par le Président de la République au
cours de ces 5 dernières années les
budgets avaient trop souvent été guidés
par les fait d'annonce les objectifs de
création de place du plan social
grandâge étant gonflé sans prendre en
compte la lenteur de leur application à
contrario le budget 2013 donne la
priorité aux établissements et services
en finançant un taux de reconduction de
leur moyenne de 4 % ce qui est beaucoup
par rapport à la casi stagnation qu'ils
ont subi auparavant en outre un effort
important est consacré à la
médicalisation des établissements ce qui
devrait permettre à terme de créer 7000
postes de personnes de personnel
soignant pour autant les plans de
création de place ne sont pas délaissés
puisque les crédits prévus permettront
l'ouverture de 3200 places pour les
personnes âgées et de 3000 places pour
les personnes
handicapé je ne reviendrai pas sur
l'examen des quatre principaux articles
rattachés spécifiquement au secteurs qui
nous qui nous occupe ainsi que deux
articles complétés par nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale les éléments ont
été abandamment développés par notre
excellent rapporteur ronand cadraon dont
je félicite et salue le travail
accompli non ça va ça va j'insisterai en
revanche sur un point la mise en
chantier du dossier de la dépendance et
l'annonce d'un projet de loi sur la
prise en charge de la perte d'autonomie
annoncée pour le début de l'année 2014
par le gouvernement promise par Nicolas
Sarkozi en 2007 indéfiniment repoussé
tout au long de quinena est
définitivement abandonné en septembre
2011 il était en effet urgent d'agir et
de rassurer nos nos anciens et leurs
famillees qui se trouvent de plus en
plus nombreux confrontés à des
situations difficiles et douloureuses
il nous faut donc rapidement dégager des
moyens supplémentaires afin de réduire
un le reste à charge des personnes
hébergées en établissement de en
remédiant aux difficultés des
départements pour financer laallocation
personnalisée d'autonomie le présent
projet prévoit donc d'ors et déjà 700
millions de recettes supplémentaires
pour la caisse Caisse nationale de
sécurité et d'autonomie à partir de 2014
je parle bien là bien sûr de l'article
16 et soyons clair mes chers collègues
la progression des cotisations pour
assurer le financement était attendue
réagissant aux conclusions du rapport
parlementaire sur la dépendance de la
députée UMP Valérie Rosseau de bord qui
préconisait à l'époque la souscription
obligatoire d'une assurance privée
François Hollande à l'époque candidat
avait affiché très clairement lors d'une
d'une émission télévisée du 12 février
dernier sa position il n'y aura pas de
contrat d'assurance privé ajoutant sans
non sans courage lors de cette interview
l'instauration d'une cotisation
dépendance pour l'ensemble des Français
je le cite attendre encore serait une
faute morale impardonnable ce serait
refuser de regarder la réalité en face
ce serait refuser d'assumer mes
responsabilités pourquoi refuser
d'assumer ses responsabilités parce que
c'est difficile mais qui pourrait
comprendre que l'on ne s'attaque pas à
un problème grave parce qu'il est dit
difficile que prévoit alors l'article 16
au 1er avril 2013 les retraites
imposables dont l'impôt dépasserai 61 €
seront soumises à un prélèvement de 0,3
%. toutes les retraites ne seront donc
pas touchées et c'est important de le
dire par cette contribution
contrairement à ce que l'on peut nous
faire croire ici et là
contrairement
concrètement pour une pension de 1300 €
pour une personne seule le montant
prélevé serait de
3,90 €. je répète
3,90 € par mois en
2014 rapportant cela aux familles aux
inquiétudes des familles chers collègues
je pense que cela est quand même
dérisoire c'est bien une mesure
solidaire et
juste globalement les retraités se
disent d'ailleurs prêts à participer à
cet effort de solidarité si l'objectif
est clairement défini et c'est bien de
cela qu'il s'agit il y a donc un
gouvernement mes chers collègues
aujourd'hui qui agit c'est aussi ce que
nous allons faire grâce aux dispositions
de l'article 41 il s'agit de fudifier
les parcours de soins des personnes
âgées afin qu'elles reçoivent les bons
soins au bon moment et qu'elles puissent
choisir librement entre établissement et
domicile cette mesure inaugure la
politique de prévention qui devra être
développé et qui permettra aussi de
réduire le coût global de la dépendance
le CH le chantier de la dépendance est
engagé mes chers collègues le
gouvernement agit avec courage et
justice et il me semble que c'est ce que
les Français attendent
aujourd'hui merci ma chè collègue la
parole est à Madame Catherine procasscia
pour le groupe
UMP
bonsoir ça
va euh monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la Présidente la
commission des affaires sociales euh
monsieur le
rapporteur général mes chers collègues
euh madame mesdame Touren et bertinoti
ont évoqué tout à l'heure la priorité
les priorités sur la
famille dans ce budget
ça me surprend un petit peu parce que
j'ai trouvé ce projet de PLFSS plutôt
indigeent en matière de budget familial
et un seul mot m'est venu pour essayer
de le caractériser c'est vide il est
vide textuellement il n'y a que deux
articles dans le texte qui ont été
proposé par le gouvernement il est vide
financièrement puisque les 400 millions
d'euros de recette voté lors du PLFR cet
été ont déjà été intégralement dépensé
dans l'éphémère augmentation de la
location de rentrée scolaire qui ont qui
a déjà été oublié par tous et vous
n'avez pas cherché à réduire le déficit
de la branche où vous n'avez pas
présenté de mesures plus ambitieuses
j'ai été également très étonné de
découvrir votre résignation à maintenir
la taxe sur les contrats d'assurance
maladie solidaire et responsable la TSCA
alors que vous y étiez farouchement
opposé je rappelle que l'an passé je
salue la disposition qu'avait présenté
notre rapporteur général et que la
Commission qui avait proposé un
amendement de suppression moi qui esti
toujours été opposé parce que ce sont
les assurés je le répète qui pèent sur
cout je vous aurais suivi avec plaisir
même si c'était une des propositions du
président du candidat à la à l'époque
Hollande cependant rien pour l'instant
sur la
TSCA concernant les dépenses je voudrais
faire plusieurs remarques tout d'abord
le versement entiers payant du
complément de mode de garde pour les
familles modestes ressent les
problématiques d'accueil des jeunes
enfants et du choix de mode de garde par
leurs parents j'y suis favorable c'est
l'occasion pour moi de souligner
l'action volontariste du gouvernement de
François Fillon qui aura tenu son
engagement d'atteindre 200000 places
d'accueil dont la moitié en accueil
collectif parmi les modes de garde celui
à domicile demeure le plus répandu en
raison de sa souplesse et de la
souplesse qu'il présente sur l'ensemble
du territoire mais aussi en raison des
horaires qui peuvent être plus flexibles
qu'en accueil collectif c'est aussi le
plus coûteux pour les parents et à cet à
cet égard je crains les conséquences du
Tour de VI donné à la niche nounou
en effet le projet de loi table
naïvement sur l'hypothèse que les
familles vont conserver leur mode de
garde et les même modalité de paiement
il n'en sera rien en touchant au crédit
d'impôt vous allez démolir le vecteur
fiscal qui a permis de lutter en partie
contre le travail dissimulé il est donc
réaliste de prévoir un retour aux
pratiques de fraude et de travail non
déclaré si répandu avant la Loi sur les
services à la personne de
2005 nombreux parents qui ont déjà
énormément de difficultés à trouver une
nounou qui accepte d'être déclaré je
vous assure c'est la réalité en région
parisienne c'est la réalité dans ma
commune c'est la réalité dans mon
département vont revenir au système D en
déclarant moins d'heur ou à un tarif
plus faible en Espagne où la même mesure
a été votée récemment le volume mensuel
d'heur de travail déclaré des nourrices
a diminué de 30 %. la conséquence
immédiate de cette mesure sera AA de
faire basculer dans l'illégalité
plusieurs milliers de salariés et les
entreprises spécialisées les employants
et aussi de diminuer les rentrées
fiscales l'inverse du but recherché je
crains en outre que cette mesure touche
de plein fouet les femmes et encore plus
les femmes seules car le surenissement
du coût incitera cell dont les salaires
sont les plus modèste à rester chez
elles les éloignant ainsi un peu plus de
l'emploi à mon avis vous roulez en
contesens et à grande vitesse c'est
dangereux vous allez provoquer un
accident démographique en remettant en
cause un élément important de la
politique familiale un dernier point a
attiré mon attention et m'a d'autant
plus surpris que j'estime qu'il n'a pas
sa place dans le plfcs il s'agit du
congé de paternité et d'accueil de
l'enfant dont plusieurs des ministres
intervenus à cette tribune se sont
félicités cette transformation qui a été
adoptée par par voix d'amendement à
l'Assemblée nationale me paraît
prématuré le Conseil des ministres vient
d'adopter votre projet de mariage entre
personnes du même sexe dont le texte
devrait être débattu dans quelques mois
au Parlement non seulement ce texte
constituerait un cadre juridique plus
approprié que le PLFSS mais n'anticipera
pas sur des dispositions souhaitées par
une minorité de personnes et que vous
voulez opposer à toutes les familles
sans compter les aspects juridiques de
cet article en reconnaissant le rôle du
ou de la partenaire de la mère en
matière de congé vous niz totalement le
père naturel de l'enfant qui peut lui
aussi vouloir contribuer à l'accueil de
cet enfant qui arbitera le conflit quels
seront les recours telleles sont les
raisons pour lesquelles avec mes
collègues nous souhaitons la suppression
de cet article enfin et même si ce point
n'est pas formellement dans la branche
famille jeite je souhaite terminer mon
intervention sur la contraception des
mineurs
la limite minimale à 15 ans me paraît
incompréhensible préférerez-vous que la
jeune fille de 14 ans et de quelques
mois doivent subir une IVG plutôt que de
rembourser ses contraceptifs nos
collègues médecins devraient vous
confirmer qu'ils ont déjà dû prendre en
charge très souvent des jeunes filles de
moins de 15 ans j'avais déposé un
amendement pour aller dans ce sens mais
l'article 40 est tombé telle une
guillotine cet âge de 15 ans a peut-être
été choisi parce que c'était auparavant
l'âge minimal pour se marier mais cet
âge n'existe plus il se me paraît très
dangereux par rapport à vos ambitions
que vous limitiez aux jeunes filles de
15 à moins de 18 ans en conclusion je
voudrais dire que le budget de la
branche famille ne montre absolument pas
contrairement à ce que vous avez dit en
début de cet après-midi votre volonté de
les aider et de continuer à les inciter
à avoir des enfants ces enfants qui
jusqu'à présent était notre
richesse merci ma chère collègue la
parole est à Madame Patricia silinget
pour le groupe
socialiste il sont terribles hein ouais
ouais
je monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le rapporteur général mes chers
collègues
mon intervention portera essentiellement
sur la branche vieillesse je tiens à
souligner ici l'excellent travail du
rapporteur Madame Christiane
deess le redressement de la situation
financière de la branche vieillesse
s'inscrit parfaitement dans la stratégie
globale des finances publiques que le
gouvernement a décidé de mettre en œuvre
le budget vieillesse qui nous est
présenté aujourd'hui est un budget
responsable car le déf cite de la
branche retraite sous tout régime de
base confondu sera ramené à 5,4 milliard
d'euros contre 7,1 milliards en 2012 de
même le déficit du fond de solidarité
vieillesse s'élévera à 2,6 milliards
d'euros contre 4,1 milliards l'année
précédente on ne peut que s'en féliciter
ainsi le gouvernement a pris la peine la
pleine mesure de la gravité de la
situation en prenant des mesur de
justice tout en réduisant des déficits
ce PLFSS prend en compte les difficultés
financières croissante que connaissent
certains régimes de retraite de base
autre que le régime général plus d'un
milliard de recettes supplémentaires
bénéficiera à la branche vieillesse du
régime des exploitants agricoles à la
Caisse nationale de retrait des agents
des collectivités locales à la Caisse
nationale d'assurance vieillesse des
professions libérales et au régime de
retraite spécial des industries
électriques et gazières dès la prise de
ces fonctions le gouvernement a montré
sa volonté de rétablir une justice
sociale en effet en juillet dernier il a
élergi aux personnes ayant commencé à
travailler avant 20 ans la possibilité
de partir en retraite dès 60 ans
lorsqu'elles ont cotisé une carrière
complète il s'agit d'une mesure d'équité
pour les assurer ayant cotisé la durée
d'assurance nécessaire autre mesures qui
mettent fin aux injustices attribution
des de points gratuits de retraite
proportionnel aux exploitants agricooles
contraint de cesser leur activité pour
infirmités ou maladies graves nouvelles
règles relatives aux pensions de
réversion pour les professions médicales
et le régime des marins permettez-moi de
m'attarder sur la mesure essentielle
concernant les exploitants agricoles
aujourd'hui les nonsariés agricoles qui
ont dû cesser leur activité en raison
d'une maladie ou d'une infirmité grave
et qui sont bénéficiaires soit d'une
pension d'invalidité soit d'une rang
d'incapacité soit de l'allocation adulte
handicapé ne s'ouvre des droits qu'à la
retraite forfaitaire il nonont aucun
droit à la retraite proportionnelle qui
constitue pourtant avec la pension
forfaitaire la retraite de base des non
salariés agricooles conformément à
l'engagement pris par la par le
Président de la République l'article 60
prévoit d'attribuer des points gratuits
de retraite proportionnell aux
exploitants agricoles qui ont dû cesser
leur activité en raison d'une maladie ou
d'une infirmité grave les périodes
d'interruption de l'activité feront
l'objet d'une validation au titre de la
retraite proportionnelle des
agriculteurs et de l'attribution d'un
nombre minimal de points gratuits les
non salariés concernés sont les chefs
d'exploitation ou d'entreprises
agricooles ainsi que les collaborateurs
d'exploitation et les aides familiaux
qui bénéficient de la retraite
proportionnelle selon l'étude d'impact
le nombre forfaitataire de points de
retraite proportionnelle sera de 23
points pour les chefs d'exploitation et
de 16 points pour les collaborateurs
d'exploitation et les aides familiaux
ces points seront attribués y compris
pour les périodes d'invalidité antérieur
à la publication de la loi cette mesure
de justice sociale prouve la volonté du
gouvernement de prendre en compte la
condition sociale de nos agriculteurs et
de protéger certains salariés au moment
de leur retraite je vous remercie madame
la
ministre ici un problème qui me tient
particulièrement à cœur c'est celui de
l'allocation équivalent retraite la er
je pense que ce dispositif qui était
essentiel doit être revu cette
allocation reposant sur la solidarité
nationale répondait à une urgence
sociale cette C vécu par des dizaines de
milliers de personnes sans revenu ayant
commencé leur carrière professionnelle
très tôt disposant des trimestres de
cotisation requis souvent au chômage
depuis plusieurs années mais n'ayant pas
atteint l'âge de 60 ans pour partir en
retraite je rappelle que ce dispositif a
permis à des milliers de chômeurs de ne
pas sombrer dans la précarité lors du
vote du projet de loi pour 2008 la
majorité de droite vota la fin de l'ER
au 1er janvier 2009 sous prétexte
d'économie mais surtout du fameux
travailler plus pour gagner plus le
calcul était simple ces anciens un
locataire allait vite retrouver un
travail et ne coûterait ainsi plus rien
à la collectivité nationale
malheureusement la crise est passé par
là en 2008 et elle a été très violente
en particulier pour les plus de 55 ans
beaucoup d'entre eux ont été incités à
partir en pleine tourmente pensant
sauver une entreprise ou libérer la de
la place pour les plus jeunes beaucoup
d'entre eux ont été ont saisi cette
occasion conforté dans l'idée que l'AER
allait les aider à passer le cap
douloureux d'un chômage de longue durée
malheureusement ces personnes ont vite
découvert avec effroi qu'elle pouvait
tout tout juste prétendre à laallocation
Spécifique de Solidarité ainsi dans
l'attente de leur retraite des 960 € de
revenus maximum prévu par l'A
50 % de ces seniors non'ont ont perçu
que la moitié devant l'ampleur de la
contestation mais aussi face à la
réalité économique le gouvernement
Fillon a finalement prolongé laaer deux
fois en 2009 et 2010 la loocation
transitoire des de solidarité a été
créée au 1er janvier 2012 destiné en
théorie à résoudre les difficultés des
de ces chômeurs en fin de droit preuve
est faite jour après jour que ce
dispositif manque sa cible puisque comme
par hasard moins de 10 % des
allocataires potentiels en sont
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui nous devons
agir vite et j'ai confiance en notre
gouvernement pour qu'il trouve une
solution ce PLFSS doit être l'OC
l'occasion de réparer une faute
magistrale de la droite il doit être
aussi l'occasion de rappeler à ces
concitoyens qu'ils peuvent compter sur
la solidarité nationale par ailleurs je
me réjouis que le gouvernement ait pris
la décision d'entreprendre une réforme
globale du système de retraite en 2013
elle permettra non seulement de remettre
à plat rapidement le système des
retraites mais aussi de combler les
déséquilibres et les inégalités par
exemple il faudra revenir sur la prise
en compte de la pénbilité dans le droit
à la retraite car elle constitue un
enjeu d'équité de grande importance
on constate de fortes inégalités
d'espérance de vie entre catégories
socio-professionnelles or les critères
de mise en œuvre de la retraite pour
pénbilité se sont avérés trop
restrictifs le nombre de demandes de
retraite pour pénbilité se situe
d'ailleurs bien endessà des prévisions
établies en 2010 de plus la situation de
la branche vieillesse risque fortement
de se dégrader à l'horizon 2017 en
l'absence de mesures structurelles
nouvelle décidée en 2013 d'où
l'importance d'une réforme globale des
retraites elle est en effet très
attendue l'issue de la concertation
prévue au 1er semestre 2013 sur le
fondement des projections démographiques
et financières établies par le corps fin
2012 permettront de prendre de nouvelles
mesures pour finir ces dernières années
on a vu le déficit s'accumulé et les
réponses n'étaient pas à la hauteur des
problèmes après 5 PLFSS de régression
nous passons enfin un PLFSS de
protection tout en redressant les
comptes sociaux le PLFSS présenté par le
gouvernement réduit les injustices en
direction de certains salariés au moment
de leur retraite des familles
vulnérables des Français en situation
difficilees et des femmes face au
contexte financier particulièrement
difficile et face à l'inquiétude
grandissante des Français l'ambition du
PLFSS porte sur la protection le
redressement et la modernisation il
répond aux attentes sociales de justice
et de proximité des Français je vous
remercie merci ma chè collègue la parole
est à à Monsieur René Paul Savari pour
le groupe
UMP
bien monsieur le président madame la
présidente madame la ministre monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues mon
intervention portera sur le secteur
médico-social de ce PLFSS et sur la
politique de la famille puisque mon
collègue et et confrère alain Milon a
déjà développé les arguments de notre
groupe en ce qui concerne le volet
sanitaire ce volet notamment le volet
médico-social est un chapitre
particulièrement important bien entendu
ce pfss plus de 13 milliards d'euros
seront consacrés notamment aux
établissements pour les personnes âgées
et pour les personnes handicapé
d'ailleurs l'ONDAM à ce titre
progressera de 4 % plus rapidement que
l'ONDAM sanitaire donc en période de 17
budgétaire et le mot 17 est bien faible
cela intrigue et ce gouvernement
semblerait faire mieux que le précédent
sans proposition nouvelle sur la
dépendance en attend pendant la future
loi à y regarder de plus près l'affaire
est peut-être plus subtile que
cela je me suis attardé sur les mesures
impactant notamment les conseils
généraux acteurs essentiels du médico
social d'autant plus que le premier
ministre avait bien dit lors de
l'entretien des présidents de conseil
généraux avec le président de la
République qu'il serait tout à fait
ouvert à regarder avec bienveillance les
amendements susceptibles de prendre en
compte un certain nombre de problèmes
collectivement
reconnus il faut en convenir
l'articulation entre le sanitaire et le
médicos-ocial n'est pas facile les
interven les intervenants pardon sont
particulièrement nombreux sécurité
sociale c'est C NSA RS knaf et sur le
territoire ce sont bien sûr les
présidents de conseil généraux qui sont
en première ligne et qui portent cette
lourde responsabilité
hélas la situation s'aggrave au fil du
temps pour certains je pense au conseils
généraux alors que d'autres ne dépensent
pas tout leur budget je pense à à la
CNSA et que certains fonds ne sont pas
affectés à leur destination première et
je penserai particulièrement au Fond
national pour l'enfance en ce qui
concerne la médicalisation des
établissements pour personnes âgées la
sous-consommation dans la section
personnes âgées et je vais y venir de
l'objectif de gestion déléguée ogogd de
la Caisse nationale de solidarité pour
l'autonomie devrait atteindre en 2012
200 millions d'euros et vous avez
annoncé malgré cette sous-consommation
que 160 millions d'euros était prévu
pour poursuivre le programme de
médicalisation des établissements
hébergeant les personnes âgées dans le
cadre de la généralisation de cette
médicalisation que l'on appelle la
patosification il convient viendrait
peut-être de mettre fin à une situation
que l'on peut qualifier sans exagération
d'absurde en effet si l'État peut
librement décider d'améliorer la
médicalisation des épad et dégager des
financements à travers ce PLFSS il ne
peut exiger que les départements
accompagnent systématiquement cette
médicalisation et mécaniquement en la
complétant à hauteur de 30 % sur la part
en établissement et dans le contexte
financier actuel les départements ne
peuvent pas prendre en compte cette
charge incluse sur la part en
établissement ce qui a aussi pour effet
d'accroîre le ticket modérateur de la PA
donc la prise en charge des résidents le
ce qu'on en appelle le reste le reste à
charge alors les départements refusant
bien sûr euh de cofinancer cette
médicalisation qui n'était pas prévu au
départ les crédits de l'assurance
maladie ne sont pas consommés ce qui
permet à la CNSA d'être excédentaire et
cette sous-consommation des crédits de
CNSA peut opportunément me semble-t-il
permettre de constituer un fond
d'urgence pourevenenir en aide au au
département en difficulté ils le sont
presque tous maintenant ce qui est un
juste retour puisque rappelons-le 54 %
de la contribution de solidarité pour
l'autonomie au lieu d'aller à la
compensation de la pas et de la PCH va
renforcer longame de l'assurance maladie
mais quels que soient les efforts le
compte n'yz pas puisque c'est près d'un
milliard d'euros 1 milliard d'euros qui
monte au département pour compenser
simplement à 50 % la loocation
personnalisée d'autonomie en ce qui
concerne la politique de la famille et
la prise en charge des mineurs étrangers
isolés permettez-moi d'y revenir
puisqu'il serait temps de trouver une
solution faute de dispositif d'accueil
par
l'État
qui devrait logiquement mettre en place
en amont des établissements de
protection de l'enfance ce sont les
structures de droit commun de l'ARE
sociale à l'enfance des départements qui
sont conduites à prendre en charge
complètement les mineurs étrangers
isolés souvent confié d'ailleurs à ces
derniers les départements directement
par les forces de police et cette prise
en charge devient insurportable
elle relève de la politique de
l'immigration aussi les frais euh
d'entretien d'accompagnement au titre
des mineurs étrangers isolés accueillis
par les établissements tarifés par les
présidents de Conseils Généraux
devrait-il être refacturé et en tout cas
imputé sur le fond national de
protection de
l'enfance nous aurons d'ailleurs des
amendements proposés au cours de ce
débat pour aller dans cette voielà en
conclusion un certain nombre de crédits
madame la ministre de ne sont pas
affecté nous semble-t-il là où il le
faudrait la prise en charge
médico-sociale est une affaire
partenariale les difficultés des
conseils généraux gravement affaiblis
par le manque grandissant de
compensation des trois allocations de
solidarité ne sont pas pris en
cause absolument et je vais y
venir ne sont pas pris en compte à la
hauteur de l'enjeu pire certaines
décisions vont contribuer a aggravé leur
situation la médicalisation et la prise
en charge des murs isolés en sont deux
illustrations mais il y a également les
facteurs
d'acgravation qui concerne directement
le gouvernement actuel en ce qui
concerne les cotisation
ATMP des élus qui vont porter sur les
budgets notamment des départements
l'augmentation des taux de
cnrcl les transports scolaires avec une
demi-journée supplémentaire
l'augmentation du nombre de bénéficiaire
de RSA un département comme le mien
c'est 1 % par mois de bénéficiaire de
RSA supplémentaire les pénalités hursav
sur les allocations mensuelles de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance j'ai cru voir qu'un
arrêté venait d'être pris tout cela va
continuer à aggraver la situation des
départements et c'est dans le cadre
d'amélioration de situation de terrain
pas suffisamment pris en compte dans ce
PLFSS trop technique que des amendements
mérite d'être abopté et leur but le but
de ces amendements c'est pouvoir exercer
correctement les
responsabilités incombant à chaque
acteur et si le gouvernement comme l'a
annoncé le Premier ministre regarde avec
bienveillance certaines
proposition alors la situation peut
avancer en tout cas espérons-le 2014 est
loin pour la future loi sur l'autonomie
et certains départements n'attendront
pas
outre la prise en charge de la
médicalisation par l'assurance maladie
en entier dans les épades outre la prise
en charge des fineurs des mineurs
étranger isolés par l'État j'ai fait des
propositions en accord avec
l'ADF comme tous les ans sur des
modifications de prise en charge des
patients entrant notamment dans le cadre
du plan Alzheimer où ça prise en compte
de la progression de la masse salariale
li à des décisions nationales et non
locales pour les établissements sociaux
et
médicaux-sociaux madame la ministre ces
réclamations n'ont pas changé elles sont
soutenu depuis des années par
l'Association des départements de France
elles paraissent comprise par tous mais
aucun signe n'est encore donné et si la
proposition de loi roche qui envisagea
une compensation de l' pas à 50 % pour
les départements par l'élargissement des
bases prises en compte par la journée de
solidarité a été voté par le Sénat il y
a quelques semaines ce n'est pas avec
l'accord du gouvernement donc madame la
ministre nous attendons des actes de
pied ferme dans le cadre de ce PLFSS car
nous ne voyons encore rien venir je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Jacky lemen pour
le groupe
socialiste
président comment vas-tu ça
va monsieur le
Président Madame la Ministre madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales monsieur le rapporteur général
mes chers collègues pour notre groupe
l'appréciation de ce pfss pour 2013 en
ce qui concerne la branche accident du
travail maladie professionnelle sur
laquelle je souhaite intervenir ce soir
s'inscrit dans une volonté forte et
permanente de voir consolider notre
système de protection sociale dans cet
esprit mon intervention portera d'abord
sur l'évocation des dernières
statistiques inquiétantes de
sinistralité ensuite sur la situation
financière de la branche ATMP enfin je
soulignerai les mesures de justice ayant
TR à cette branche contenu dans ce
pfss selon les derniers chiffres
officiels disponibles ceux de la année
2010 le nombre d'accidents du travail et
de maladies professionnelles a augmenté
680000 accidents du travail plus 1,1 %
donc 45000 accidents graves
55057 maladies professionnelles plus de
7 % plus d'un personne par jour décèdent
d'un accident du travail ou des suites
d'une maladie professionnelle plus d'une
personne par jour 3000 personnes meurent
chaque année en France en raison de la
miante par ailleurs on observe une
augmentation du travail de nuit qui
concerne aujourd'hui 3,5 millions de
personnes pour les femmes cette hausse
constitue un facteur de risque
supplémentaire l'étude de l'incerme
Cécile mené en 2010 dans le département
des côes d'Armor et dans mon département
d'il vilen montre que le risque du
cancer du sein est augmenté de 30 % chez
les femmes ayant travaillé de nuit les
conditions de travail ont un impact
direct sur la santé les personnes les
plus exposées à la pénibilité sont
celles dont l'espérance de vie à 35 ans
et la plus faible les conditions
d'emploi ont aussi un impact non
négligeable les salariés sous contrat
précaire sont plus exposés à des
troubles dépressifs à des accidents et à
des maladies dans la mesure où leur
formation à la sécurité est moindre et
où ils travaillent sur des postes à
risque enfin il il faut rappeler que sur
longue période depuis 2001 les dépenses
de la branche ATMP pour les maladies
professionnelles sont passé de 1 à 2,2
milliards soit 20 % des dépenses de
branche cette évolution négative de la
sinistralité liée au travail n'est pas
admissible sur le plan humain et de
moins en moins supportable sur le plan
financier une situation financière de la
branche ATMP très fragilisée depuis 2003
une dette cumulée en augmentation la
branche ATMP est en déficit après une
quarantaine d'années excédentaires
depuis 2003 la branche a connu une
succession de déficit cite allant de 100
à 700 millions en 2009 et 2010 d'où une
dette cumulée de 1,7 milliards d'euros
selon le rapport sénatorial de noscollè
poefroid et de roche fin juillet 2012
pour la 2e année consécutive par
ailleurs en 2012 la Cour des comptes a
refusé de certifier les comptes de la
branche ATMP en raison des insuffisances
cumulatives du contrôle interne et de
l'activité de recouvrement portant
atteinte à l'exhaustivité et à
l'exactitude des codisisations sociales
affectées à la branche ATMP vocabulaire
inimitable pour qualifier l'obscurité de
gestion les raisons structurelles et
conjoncturelles de la dette les
transferts vers d'autres branches les
transferts vers d'autres régime ont été
en 2011 de 2,562 milliards en
augmentation de 1,8 % par rapport à 2010
il représente maintenant 21,7 % des
charges imputables à la branche ATMP ce
qui interpelle sur le plan structurel
sur la branche maladie le transfert est
en 2012 de 790 millions d'euros au motif
habituel de la sous-déclaration et de la
sousreconnaissance des ATMP sur la
branche JIS la contribution pour les
départs anticipés à la retraite pour
pénibilité et de 110 millions d'euros en
2012 après 37 millions en 2011 elle ne
figure pas dans l'avantprjet du pfsf
pour 2013 le gouvernement indique que
les crédits non utilisés de 2012 sont
suffisants pour couvrir aussi 2013 à
raison de 300 à 400 demandes par mois il
est prévu que cette contribution
n'existe plus à la suite de la prochaine
réforme de 2013 sur les retraites ce qui
nous apparaît sain et positif sur les
fonds destinés aux victimes de laamante
pour 2013 les montants proposés sont
respectivement de 115 millions d'euros
pour le FIVA soit une économie de 200
millions par rapport à 2011 et 2012 et
de 890 millions pour la FCA ATA pour le
FIVA le gouvernement indique que le fond
de roulement s'élève 350 millions
suffisants pour couvrir 2013 nous en
prenons acte et que la dotation sera
revue au niveau nécessaire pour
courouvrir les besoins en 2014 nous
faisons totalement conférence au
gouvernement pour cet engagement deuxème
raison de la dette la faiblesse de la
progression de la masse salariale
chômage partiel licenciement précarité
dans les secteurs notamment à forte
sinistralité d'où la nécessité absolue
de relancer la croissance auquel
s'attelle d'ailleurs notre gouvernement
la progression du consensueux plus 70
millions par rapport à 2010 soit 520
millions le coût des procédures
contentieuses pour la branche a explosé
depuis plusieurs années il a atteint en
2011 la somme de 520 millions il pèse
donc de façon non négligeable sur le
résultat comptable de la branche
ATMP la réforme de l'instruction des
procédures ATMP prévu par le décret du
29 juillet 2009 entré en application le
1er janvier 2010 a pour objet de limiter
cette inflation procédurière c'est en
effet un véritable marché qui s'est peu
à peu créé sur ce point avec
l'externalisation de la gestion du
risque ATMP vers des cabinets
spécialisés et la systématisation des
recours ce faisant nombre de grandes
entreprises ont cessé de s'impliquer
dans la gestion de ce risque ce qui est
particulièrement
regrettable quelle solution peut-être
proposée pour assiner la situation de
cette dette de cette
branche avec un déficit cumulé de 17
milliards d'euros que la cosos estime à
2,2 milliards d'euros en prenant en
compte les besoins de fonds de roulement
et le calendrier transfert à d'autres
branches il est évident qu'une
augmentation des cotisations des
employeurs devient inévitable au
demeurant il convient de rappeler que si
le taux moyen actuel n'est que de
2,365 % de la de la masse salariale il
était en 1981 de 4 %. depuis il a connu
une série de baisses don une importante
en 1993 passant alors à 26 % sans que
cette baisse soit justifié par une
diminution significative des ATMP ou une
responsabilisation particulièrement
remarquable des entreprise en matière de
prévention-moi c'est de la
bière considérant que 0,1 points de
cotisation représente environ 500
million
payész-vous
là-bas payé par 2,3 million d'employeurs
cotisant une augmentation unique qui
pourrait être une solution de 04 points
représenter représenterait immédiatement
la résorption de la dette toutefois
cette mesure budgétaire est inappropriée
dans le contexte économique actuel le
gouvernement nous propose donc une autre
approche plus adapté pour à la fois
prendre en compte la fragilité de la
situation financière de la branche ATMP
et commencer à apurer la dette cumulée
tout en créant et finançant des mesures
de justice pour mieux accompagner les
les victimes du monde du travail ce qui
ne peut que recueillir l'adhésion de
notre groupe parlementaire s'agissant de
l'amélioration de la structure
financière de la branche en 2013 en
tendantiel c'est-à-dire sans mesurees
correctrices le déficit de la branche
devrait atteindre 154 millions d'euros
avec les nouvelles mesures proposées
dans le budget qui nous est présenté à
savoir premièrement le relèvement de
0,05 points des des cotisations dues par
les employeurs deuxièmement
l'amélioration du recouvrement des
sommes dues en cas de faute inexcusable
de l'employeur prévu à l'article 66 du
pdfss qui devrait rapporter 10 millions
d'euros en 2013 troisièmement la
diminution aujourd'hui possible de la
dotation au priva la branche ATMP sera
donc excédentaire à hauteur de 300
millions d'euros régime général il
s'agit donc là d'un point très positif
puisque serait enfin stoppé
l'augmentation de la dette avec en
perspective sa résorption à moyen terme
s'agissant des mesure de justice et
d'équité prévu dans ce PLFSS
elles étaient attendues avec impatience
par les intéressés et leurs associations
représentative ainsi l'actuelle
majoration pour tierces personnes sera
remplacée par la création de la
prestation d'aide à l'emploi pour
tierses personnes pour les victimes
d'atmp mesur prévu à l'article 65 du
pfss cet article répond à une
revendication justifiée des partenaires
sociaux dans l'accord interprofessionnel
du 12 mars 2007 sur la prévention la
tarification et la réparation des
risques professionnels les salariés dont
l'incapacité permanente par suite d'un
sinistre professionnel bien sûr est d'au
moins 80 % et qui sont dans l'incapacité
d'effectuer les actes ordinaires de
l'existence sans l'assistance d'autrui
bénéficie d'une majoration pour tiersces
personnes aujourd'hui le montant de
cette prestation n'est pas fondé sur
leurs besoins réels l'article 65
applicable au 1er janvier 2013 crit donc
une nouvelle prestation dont le montant
ne sera plus fonction du montant de la
rente mais seulement des besoins
d'assistance de la personne il s'agit
bien d'une mesure de justice sociale que
je soulligne et d'équité qui est tout à
l'honneur ce gouvernement le financement
de cette mesure représente 0,01 point de
hausse de cotisation employeur compris
dans les 0,0 points dont j'ai fait état
précédemment ainsi encore des mesures
faisant l'objet de l'article 66 du PLFSS
comme l'obligation d'un rembourse ement
immédiat par l'employeur du capital
représentatif de la hausse de la rente
en cas de faute inexcusable ayant causé
un accident du travail ou une maladie
professionnelle ainsi enfin pour les
travailleurs victimes de la miante le
PLFSS prévoit à l'article 67 d'étendre à
tous les régimes de retraite la
possibilité de liquider sa pension desès
60 ans en cas de carrière complète pour
les bénéficiaires d'une allocation de
cessation anticipée d'activité
auparavant cette néta ouverte que dans
certains régimes des différences de
traitement injustifié et
particulièrement choquantes vont donc
pouvoir être corrigé pour conclure je
dirais que ce pfss pour 2013 notamment
pour son volet àmp va dans le bon sens
et que mon groupe votera les articles
concernant tout comme il votera
d'ailleurs l'ensemble du pfss en pleine
confiance merci mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur JeanÉtienne pour
le groupe
socialiste monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre chers collègues le thème de
la transition semble être le fil
conducteur de la discussion autour de ce
projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour
2013 amélioration tout d'abord puisque
un héritage financier catastrophique
succède un effort de redressement des
comptes sociaux temporisation ensuite
car s'il reprend nombre d'objectifs
formulés par le Sénat ce budget ne porte
pas encore les réformes d'ampleur
nécessaires au renforcement de notre
protection
sociale mais en laissant du temps au
Haut Conseil pour la protection sociale
ce budget pour 2013 propose néanmoins
des mesures importantes pour protéger
notre système de santé contre les
atteintes qui lui ont été portées c'est
donc bien de rénovation qu'il
s'agit transition encore dans l'examen
législatif l'attention que les élus
d'autre maère connaissent
particulièrement bien entre les
préoccupations sociales légitimes les
solutions que l'on pense les mieux
adapté pour améliorer la condition de
nos concitoyens et la nécessaire
solidarité avec un gouvernement que l'on
souhaite toujours plus à l'écoute menace
de réduire la discussion de ce budget
devant notre assemblée un bref épisode
entre deux prises de décision de nos
collègues du Palais Bourbon ce risque me
conduit à traiter de deux mesures
particulières sur lesquelles je souhaite
attirer l'attention la première est le
financement de l'hôpital à raison ce
projet de financement de la sécurité
sociale abroche la convergence tarifaire
et reporte l'application de la
tarification à l'acte à raison encore ce
budget double la dotation destinée au
fond de modernisation des établissements
de santé et illustre la priorité donnée
à l'hôpital il me rient il me revient
cependant d'insister encore sur la
faiblesse de la prise en compte du
caractère singulier de la situation des
établissements de santé en outre mer
l'offre de soins dans ces départements
est plus qu'insuffisante
les difficultés y sont multipliées par
des charges bien supérieures à celles
supportées par les établissements
métropolitains la prise en compte des
frais des évacuations sanitaires de la
Guyane vers la Martinique ou la
métropole ceux de la à la difficulté de
recroutement de praticiens spécialistes
aux indemnités de vie chère des
personnels est-il encore besoin de
rappeler ce qui fait le surcût financier
des entreprises de santé en outreem un
exemple suffit pour illustrer les
conditions d'exercice budgétaire
proprement hallucinant du centre
hospitalier de Cayenne le mètre cube
d'oxygène liquide lui revient à 9800 €
alors qu'il coûte autour de 300 € en
métropole le surcout dépasse ainsi le 1
million d'euros pour le budget annuel de
cet
établissement il apparaît donc
nécessaire que la revalorisation du
coefficient géographique correct
et la répartition du financement des
missions d'intérêt général et d'aide à
la contractualisation se fasse et tienne
compte des besoins des acteurs locaux de
santé pour une offre de soins d'une
qualité identique sur l'ensemble du
territoire les praticiens ont chiffré à
30 % le coefficient géographique contre
26 % aujourd'hui pas seulement en Guyane
mais également en Martinique ou en
Guadeloupe cette mesure nécessaire pour
éviter l'étranglement financier des
centres de soins dans les départements
français d'Amérique aura-t-elle une
traduction pour mars
prochain par ailleurs comme dans de
nombreuses régions de France la
démographie médicale est sinistrée en
outrem notamment en guyan si en dehors
des différentes incitations financières
visant à augmenter l'affectivité d'un
territoire vis-à-vis des professionnels
de santé les réponses à apportter
interviennent sur plusieurs champs qui
vont bien au delelà du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale il
est important que cette problématique
soit avancée comme une priorité lors de
nos débats l'offre de soins étant
déterminé par l'État par le biais
notamment du numérus clausus et
différents schémas d'organisation il
s'agira peut-être par la voie
législative de mieux organiser la
répartition de cette offre de soin sur
le territoire français pour davantage
d'égalité je pense qu'il est inutile de
raeler que les inégalités de santé ont
elles aussi un impact défavorable sur
les dépenses prise en charge tardif du
patient qui en alordit le
coup la seconde transition que je
souhaite aborder à propos de ce budget
est celle du régime de cotisation des
particuliers
employeurs le gouvernement avance de
sérieux arguments pour la suppression de
l'assiette forfaitaire l'abrogation
d'une niche fiscale ne bénéficiant pas à
la protection sociale des employés se
justifie au regard de son coût toutefois
cette suppression du choix de la
cotisation forfaitaire entraîne celle
d'autres régimes spéciaux fondés sur
cette
possibilité ainsi dans les départements
d'utr ma la cotisation sociale
forfaitaire d pour l'emploi à domicile
était établie depuis
1994 sur une assiette de
0,76 % du SMIC dans les Antig guyan et
04 SMIC à la Réunion l'étude d'impact du
projet de loi de financement de la de la
sécurité sociale reste muette sur les
conséquences de l'application de cette
abrogation générale au département
d'outrem qui bénéficiit de ce régime
forfaitaire
avantageux je ne peux penser madame la
ministre que vous ne serez pas attentive
à cette situation particulière et
conserverez une situation établie au
moins jusqu'à la réception des travaux
du Haut Conseil de financement de la
setion sociale au printemps prochain ou
d'une étude circonstanciée des effets de
l'abrogation de cette cotisation
forfaitaire dans les départements d'utr
m enfin le pouvoir d'achat des retraités
encore plus que celui des autres
citoyens fait débat en effet une
augmentation de la pauvreté chez les
personnes âgées conduit de plus en plus
de retraités à poursuivre
une activité pardon professionnelle
au-delà de 70 ans remettons en question
le principe même de la protection
sociale de notre démocratie cela l'est
d'autant plus dans les outr mers où les
seiors doivent faire face à une baisse
brutale de leur revenu par la
suppression des 40 % en plus du manque à
gagner résultant du calcul de la pension
alors que paradoxalement on connaît le
coût de la vie de ces régions d'outr m
or la pauvreté or la pauvreté étant ind
déterminant de santé si une transition
rapide ne s'opère pas pour une élévation
du niveau de vie des personnes
inéluctablement l'impact sur les
dépenses de santé se fera ressentir à
terme alors même que la part de ces
personnes est croissante dans la
population pour finir la transition
entre l'état actuel de notre protection
sociale et celle que nous souhaitons
pour les années futures doit être une
amélioration l'offre de soins déjà à
l'agonie en outre M ne saurait résister
à davantage de dégradation en conclusion
je voterai le budget 2013 pour la
sécurité sociale mais je resterai dans
l'écoute du gouvernement àes
préoccupations merci mon cher collègue
dernier orateur inscrit monsieur
Jean-Luc Fichet pour le groupe
socialiste madame la ministre monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Rapporteur
général madame la Présidente et mes
chers collègues la question des déserts
médicaux a pris une large place dans les
débats à l'Assemblée nationale vous avez
réaffirmer à cette occasion madame la
ministre que les difficultés d'accès aux
soins étaient une
réalité et que plusieurs actions
seraient mises en œuvre par le
gouvernement pour y
remédier l'accord sur les dépassements
d'honoraires est une première étape
contre la barrière
financière la création d'un contrat de
patricien territorial est une autre
étape vous avez annoncé un plan global à
venir et nous ne pouvons que nous en
féliciter la présence ou non de
professionnels de santé est un facteur
essentiel pour la survie de nos zones
rurales mais aussi périe urbaine cette
question a donc un sens fondamental en
terme d'aménagement du territoire c'est
la raison pour laquelle la Commission du
développement durable et de
l'Aménagement du Territoire du Sénat
s'est saisie de cette problématique à
travers la création d'un groupe de
travail sur la présence médicale
commission que j'ai l'honneur de
présider avec mon collègue rapporteur
Hervé Moret et mes collègues sénateurs
membres du groupe de travail nous avons
d'ors et déjà procédé à de nombreuses
auditions nous rendrons nos conclusions
au début de l'année 2013 et ce sera je
l'espère madame la ministre l'occasion
d'apporter des propositions nouvelles au
plus près des attentes de nos
concitoyens
tout en répondant au souhait des
professionnels de n'être plus seul dans
l'exercice d'une profction exigeante et
de pouvoir bénéficier de meilleures
conditions de vie
professionnelle sans vouloir préjuger
des conclusions de notre groupe de
travail mais afin que cette proposition
soit très présente au moment où nous
discutons du PLF SSS j'ai déposé un
amendement afin que le Sénat soit ouvert
et que différentes pistes soient exploré
je souhaite ainsi profiter de ce débat
pour rappeler que l'attente des élus est
immense sur cette question on l'a vu
l'Association des maires de France et
l'association des maires ruraux ont
chacune à leur tour lancé un appel au
secours si la présence médicale est une
grande préoccupation des élus et en
premier chef des maires c'est parce que
ce sont vers eux que ce tour les
administrés quand le service public de
santé est m à mal ce sont sont eux qui
tentent d'apporter des solutions en
investissant dans des pôles ou des
maisons de santé qui doivent être de
vraies solutions
pérenn aujourd'hui les pharmaciens les
infirmières doivent prendre en compte
l'offre existante dans les territoires
avant leur installation et orienter leur
projet vers les zones en situation de
besoin c'est ce même esprit qui peut
nous guider pour améliorer l'offre
médicale dans les secteurs en difficulté
que cela soit en milieu rural ou en zone
périurbaines j'ai souhaité également
déposer deux amendements qui ont été
consignés par l'ensemble de mes
collègues du groupe socialiste le
premier tant à engager le dialogue sur
les conséquences positif qu'aurait la
réhabilitation du métier d'herboriste
sur les comptes de la Sécurité
sociale cette question me tient
particulièrement à cœur Madame la
Ministre j'ai déposé une proposition de
loi dans ce sens le 12 juillet
2011 le Centre d'analyse stratégique qui
dépend du Premier ministre a tout
récemment publié une étude pour une
reconnaissance des médecines non
conventionnelles et au premier rang
desquelles la
phytothérapie l'achat de plantes
médicinal écrit son auteur est en forte
croissance depuis 10 ans notamment avec
la hausse de
l'automédication il ajoute en 2000 3 la
vente des plantes médicinales a été
estimée à près de 4 milliards d'euros
sur le marché européen la France où la
phyothérapie est la deuxième pratique
non conventionnelle la plus utilisée est
le deuxième marché européen des plantes
médicinales derrière l'Allemagne le
Centre d'analyse stratégique classe la
phytothérapie et
l'aromathérapie parmi les quatre
médecines non conventionnelles les plus
cour avec l'homéopathie et
l'acupuncture or le développement de
l'arboristerie permettrait de protéger
le
consommateur de donner des gages de
qualité et d'agir efficacement en
complémentarité des traitements
traditionnel et contribuerait ainsi à la
maîtrise du déficit de notre système de
sécurité sociale ce serait également une
réponse pour améliorer la prévention et
le bien-être aujourd'hui les plantes
médic
interviennent dans les traitements
contre le sida ou les cancers notamment
pour éliminer certains effets
secondaires inhérants au traitement les
plantes sont entrées à l'hôpital leur
utilité dans le processus des soins de
support est souvent trop
méconnu par ailleurs des médecins
spécialement formés à l'emploi des
plantes les
phytothérapeutes diagnosti et
prescrivent déjà l'utilisation des
plantes cet angument pour les plantes
médicinales a très certainement des
conséquences financières pour notre
système de santé puisqu'elle représente
une consommation moindre de médicaments
il convient ASI madame la ministre
d'avancer vers une reconnaissance de la
profession d'arboris qui permettrait
également de créer de nouveaux emplois
dans de multiples domaines d'améliorer
la protection des consommateurs et de
lutter contre les charlantans qui
pululent sur les
internet de favoriser la qualité la
transparence et le respect des
ressources dans une volonté de
développement durable de rendre plus
dynamique la filière agricole des
plantes en particulier vers
l'agriculture biologique et de conserver
notre patrimoine culturel commun
aujourd'hui plus de 80 % des plantes
utilisées en France sont
d'importation enfin pour conclure Madame
la Ministre j'ai déposé sur la partie
retraite avec mes collègues du groupe
socialiste un amendement afin de
demander au gouvernement un retour à
l'AER àocation équivalent retraite ou
tout du moins la mise en place d'un
dispositif moins restrictif que l'ATS
permettant aux anciens salariés
concernés qui seraient de l'ordre de
30000 en France dont de nombreuses
femmes de conserver une vie décente
jusqu'à leur retraite je vous
remercie merci mon cher collègue la
discussion générale est closeuse Madame
la Ministre souhaitez-vous répondre aux
différents
orateurs vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le Président je voudrais
tout d'abord m'adresser à à
l'opposition qui s'est
évertué au cours de la discussion à
vouloir faire passer l'idée que nous ne
proposions pas de ligne directrices ou
de mesures fortes en direction des
Français pourtant à dire
vrai c'est plutôt le le manque de
courage ou de volonté je ne sais de la
part de la droite qui au cours des
années a été des dernières années a été
criant puisque le résultat est sans
appel euh messieurs madamees messieurs
les les sénateurs le résultat est sans
appel non seulement vous n'avez pas
engagé les réformes de fond qui étaient
attendu et dont nous avons entendu
d'ailleurs qu'elle représentait ou
qu'elle répondait à des attentes fortes
qu'il s'agissent de l'accès aux soins en
termes financiers de l'élargissement des
déserts médicaux de la ise médicalisée
des dépenses de santé de la réforme des
retraites ou de la politique familiale
non seulement vous n'avez pas apporté
les réformes de fond qui étaient ou
engager les réformes de fond qui étaient
attendu mais vous avez laissé un déficit
spectaculaire à bissal qui de plus a
réduit les protections auxquelles nos
concitoyens était en droit de prétendre
et donc je ne crois pas véritablement
que vous puissiez nous accuser
aujourd'hui de ne pas présenter une
vision cohérente et globale et Monsieur
Milon vous nous avez reproché une vision
comptable alors je sais que dans votre
bouche c'est au fond une critique
minimale parce que vous-même et nous
avons eu à plusieurs reprise et vous
avez eu ici l'occasion d'en débattre euh
vous avez été j'aurai l'occasion d'y
revenir à l'origine avec d'autres de
propositions qui sont intégralement
reprises dans ce texte de loi et vous
avez beau faire il est difficile fond de
vous en démarquer mais vous l'avez fait
en tout cas avec une courtoisie toute
républicaine et puis je voudrais
indiquer par ailleurs que cela est en
quelque sorte en contradiction avec ce
que disait Monsieur Philippe B que j'ai
écouté attentivement et entendu puisque
il nous a à l'inverse non pas reproché
d'avoir une vision comptable ce qui nous
amènerait à ne nous préoccuper que
d'objectifs financiers mais d'avoir une
forme d'inconstant
budgétaire et il a fait référence aux
propositions que nous avons récemment
misise en avant sur la compétitivité de
notre économie avec une forme de
raccourci qui est difficilement
compréhensible puisque l'un des axes
forts du plan de compétitivité qui a été
annoncé il y a quelques jours il y a une
semaine et précisément de marquer de
façon très forte la différence entre une
politique une stratégie de compétitivité
de nos entreprises d'un côté et la
question du financement de la protection
sociale de l'autre parce que avec la
volonté affichée d'éviter toute
confusion des genres euh contrairement à
ce qui avait été fait au début de
l'année par la majorité de l'époque que
vous souteniez les les travaux du
hautceil pour le financement de la
protection sociale sont en cours ils
déboucheront au début de l'année
prochaine sur des propositions que nous
attendons car l'enjeu est bien de
sécuriser dans la durée le financement
d'une protection sociale à laquelle non
seulement nous sommes attachés pour ce
qui est de notre majorité mais dont nous
savons qu'elle ne n'est pas amené à
diminuer au cours des années à venir
compte tenu du vieillissement de la
population de
l'augmentation ou de l'accroissement des
besoins dus à la montée des maladies
chroniques à l'amélioration d'un certain
nombre de traitements et donc il y a
contrairement à ce que vous avez indiqué
une différence très nette dans notre
esprit entre stratégie en faveur de la
compétitivité des entreprises et mise en
place d'un financement pérenne et
durable de la protection sociale vous
avez indiqué avec une mauvaise foi
souriante je dois le reconnaître mais
enfin une mauvaise foi quand même que
nous ne mettions pas en place
suffisamment rapidement de politique de
prise en charge de la perte d'autonomie
je veux y voir un trait d'humour compte
tenu de la rapidité toute manif feste
avec laquelle vous vous êtes emparé du
sujet au cours des dernières années
quant à la question des retraites nous
avons annoncer l'engagement d'une
concertation pour l'année prochaine mais
dès ce projet de loi nous avons apporté
7 milliards de recettes supplémentaires
au régime de retraite pardonnez ou
pardonner le peu donc c'est bien que
nous avons la volonté de mettre en place
des réformes structurelles et pour ce
qui est de la mesure de retour entre gu
mais à 60 ans pour une partie de la
population elle est entièrement financée
par une hausse minime mais une hausse
d'un prélèvement qui permet d'alimenter
la sécurité sociale je voudrais
d'ailleurs indiquer que j'ai entendu
même s'il n'est plus là mais il est venu
l'évoquer rapidement j'ai entendu les
propositions de Monsieur dassasso pour
un financement pérenne de notre
protection sociale à
euh Jean-Marie van lorberg qui m'a
interrogé sur notre calendrier pour un
retour à l'équilibre je veux dire que le
l'engagement présidentiel est bien celui
et celui de la majorité et celui d'un
redressement des comptes publics à
horizon 2017 et cet objectif sera tenu
ce qui ne signifie pas que d'ici 2017 il
ne doivent pas y avoir de mesures
structurelles pour la sécurité sociale
c'est bien parce que nous engageons des
réformes structurelles que nous serons à
même de tenir cet objectif de
l'équilibre
en 2017 à mugaddini qui m'a interrogé
sur la T2A et ses prétendus effets
salutaires entre guillemets je veux
rappeler que le rapport de l'Amex j'en
reviens monsieur Milon Jaquie leemè voté
à l'unanimité a exprimé fortement la
nécessité d'un système de tarification
de l'hôpital qui évolue dans le sens de
plus de transparence de justice dans la
loocation des ressources c'est qui
favorise l'amélioration de la qualité
c'est ce que nous proposons dans ce
PLFSS pourtant Monsieur Milon qui est un
des auteurs de ce rapport avec Jacquy
lemen donc on arrive à critiquer une
mesure qu'il a lui-même préconisé la fin
de la convergence tarifaire en disant
que une suspension serait plus efficace
aujourd'hui que l'abrogation mais je
veux vous répondre monsieur le sénateur
que il n'est pas question pour nous
d'une simple parenthèse euh c'est une
mesure forte attendue par les acteurs du
système de santé et par les patients
même si les patients en réalité se
préoccupent assez peu eux-mêmes des
mécanismes de financement de l'hôpital
mais ce qu'ils veulent c'est que
l'hôpital soit garanti conforté dans les
missions qu'il porte eu enfin vous
m'avez interrogé monsieur le sénateur
sur le devenir du service de médecine de
l'adolescence du CHU de bicetre et je
veux sur ce point vous rassurer ce
service n'est pas menacé bien au
contraire l'hôpital de bicetre élabore
et porte porte un projet d'envergure qui
permettra la prise en charge globale des
adolescents intégrant également le
traitement des maladies chroniques et de
l'obésité monsieur Barbier vous avez
parlé de l'accord sur les dépassements
comme d'une stigmatisation des
professionnels de santé des médecins je
veux vous dire très fortement que le
choix de la négociation c'est tout sauf
de la stigmatisation et que le fait que
l'accord a été signé par trois cas
majoritaire indique que les médecins
dans leur immense majorité ne se sont
pas sentis stigmatisés en tout cas moi
je tiens ici à le redire les médecins
sont évidemment fondamentaux essentiels
au fonctionnement de notre système de
santé il ne peut pas y avoir de système
de santé sans médecin il ne peut pas y
avoir de système de santé globalement
sans professionnel de santé et personne
n'a cette idée- làà en tête et
j'ajouterai même que il ne peut pas y
avoir dans notre pays contte tenu de son
histoire contte tenu de la manière dont
s structuré et organisé notre système de
santé il ne peut pas y avoir de système
qui soi efficace adapté sans
professionnels libéraux pour autant est-
à dire qu'il ne doivent pas y avoir de
régulation je ne le pense pas et je
crois que ce que les patients attendent
ça n'est pas des discours idéologique
sur ces questions-là c'est précisément
la mise en place d'un système qui les
sécurise dans leur accès aux soins et de
ce point de vue-là il y a bien loin de
la stigmatisation que vous avez évoqué à
Catherine procatia qui a concentré
l'essentiel de son propos sur la branche
famille je souhaiterais rappeler qu'à
travers ce PLFSS est une politique
familiale résolument ancrée vers la
solidarité entre les famille que nous
vous proposons une politique ancrée à
gauche qui reconnaît l'ensemble des
familles toutes les familles qui dans un
même temps visent à l'égalité entre les
hommes et les femmes ainsi que la prise
en compte de nouvelle forme familiale
qui existe aujourd'hui à Monsieur Savari
je veux rappeler que
l'ondame pour 2013 permet de préserver
des moyens de haut substantiel pour le
secteur médico-social je ne suis pas
certaine d'avoir totalement suivi sa
démonstration selon laquelle il y avait
un nondat ou un sousond d'â à 4 % mais
que ce sousond d'â en réalité cachait
probablement moins que 4 %
puisque nous ne faisions pas la réforme
de la dépendance que vous n'aviez pas
faite vous le reconnaissiez et que au
fond dans la mesure où vous n'aviez pas
fait grand-chose c'est en gros ce que
vous avez dit hein c'est ce que vous
avez dit vous ne voyez pas bien comment
nous nous pouvions faire plus bon donc
je vous remercie cette démonstration qui
en tout cas avait le mérite d'indiquer
que vous n'aviez pas enfin vous votre
majorité n'avez de fait pas fait
grand-chose mais pour le reste pour le
reste je veux vous rassurer la qualité
des relations avec les conseils généraux
est une priorité pour nous et pour ma
part j'y suis extrêmement attaché
puisque je ne peux pas évidemment
oublier les fonctions que j'ai occupé à
l'évidence nous avons besoin de Solider
et de sécuriser les départements dans la
prise en charge des allocations
universelles qui leur incombent et en
particulier de la loocation
personnalisée d'autonomie c'est celle
qui a été le plus souvent évoquée dans
les débats ce soir et que vous avait
évoqué mais enfin on pourrait aussi
évoquer le RSA et
le la la PC pour ce qui est des conseils
généraux et en miroir la montée en
puissance forte de l'AH pour les état
mais vous voyez bien que c'est un
travail qui suppose de s'inscrire dans
la durée et comme j'ai eu l'occasion de
le dire nous allons organiser des
concertations approfondies dans la
perspective à la fois de la
décentralisation et de la réforme de la
perte d'autonomie pour déterminer les
relations entre l'État et les conseils
généraux ce qui passe aussi par une
réflexion sur les modes de financement
pérennes ce qui n'avait pas été le cas
dans le passé sur les modes de
financement pérenn de ces allocations je
voudrais maintenant dire aux
parlementaires de la Major que je les
remercie du
soutien fort affirmé qu'ils m'ont
apporté après celui qui avait été
exprimé par les différents rapporteurs
en introduction de ce débat certains
avant d'en venir au au soutien certains
ont fait part de certaines
interrogations cela me paraît normal et
salutaire dans une démocratie comme la
nôtre ainsi je veux dire à Catherine
Génisson qui a notamment posé qui est
au-delà de du soutien qu'elle a apporté
et et et et de euh la la la
reconnaissance de de mesures fortes
notamment dans le domaine de santé
qu'elle a relevé je voudrais donc lui
dire puisqu'elle a posé la question de
la revalorisation des actes dans le
cadre de l'accord sur les dépassements
d'honoraire ce qui est effectivement un
enjeu important que un effort
substantiel a été fait sur le tarif
opposable euh dans cet accord sur toute
une série d'actes et il est nécessaire
de mesurer la valeur que représente cet
engagement en période de crise et de
restrictions financières je veux
insister cet accord a un enjeu
fondamental c'est celui de l'accès aux
soins de nos concitoyens de lever les
obstacles qui existent pour autant il
comporte des mesures à la fois de
valorisation euh du travail des
professionnels des médecins euh engagés
en secteur 1 je pense en particulier au
tarif des médecins traitants enfin la
valeur forfait des médecins traitants
mais aussi des médecins qu'il soient en
secteur 1 ou en secteur 2 donc il
pratique ou non des dépassements
d'honorair et dont certains actes en
particulier les actes de chirurgie dont
on parle beaucoup aujourd'hui mais les
actes de chirurgie qui feront l'objet
d'une revalorisation sur les trois
prochaines années ce qui n'avait pas été
le cas à Dominique vatrin qui a appelé
de ses vœux un P LFSS qui marque le
changement je veux répondre que ce PLFSS
est bien un un projet de loi de
changement et vous avez vous-même je
vous en remercie rappelé les grandes
mesures qui figurent et que j'ai déjà
cité vous avez par ailleurs affirmé que
l'article 16 la contribution
additionnelle de solidarité sur les
pensions de retraite était je vous cite
une mesure de droite alors euh il ne
m'appartient pas de déterminer si
l'opposition dans cet hémicycle
partagera votre analyse en tout cas je
veux vous dire que je ne partage pas
cette approche et je veux en particulier
remercier Samia Gall Jean desessar qui
ont rappelé que cette mesure de justice
ne touchait pas les petites retraites et
qu'elle s'inscriv qu'elle s'inscrivait
dans une logique d'équité je veux à
nouveau euh rappeler comme je l'ai fait
tout à l'heure à la tribune
que dans l'opposition comme maintenant
dans la majorité nous avons appelé de
nos vœux une grande réforme pour
l'autonomie des personnes âgées
longtemps promise et jamais réalisé
jusqu'à ce jour pour que cette réforme
puisse s'engager sur les bases d'
financement solidaire et non pas sur les
bases de l'assurance privée nous avons
besoin d'appeler des contributions qui
soient des contribution de tous et
personne ne
comprendrait personne ne comprendrait
que les traité imposable encore une fois
soit la seule catégorie de la population
qui sur la dépendance entre guillemets
la perte d'autonomie soit donc la seule
à ne pas être mise à contribution j'en
profite pour redire ici ce que j'ai eu
l'occasion de vous dire à vous et
certains de de vos collègues que je suis
extrêmement attentive pour ne pas dire
préoccupé mais attentive àce que
l'évolution de notre système de
protection sociale
se fasse bien dans la cohésion et le
rassemblement de l'ensemble de la
population un des enjeux c'est la
lisibilité de notre système de
protection sociale un des enjeux c'est
la garantie ou comment dire la confiance
que tous les Français et en particulier
aujourd'hui les jeunes actifs mais que
tous les Français auront dans la
capacité de notre système à leur
apporter des garanties dans la durée et
donc en matiè tière de dépendance comme
nous parlons évidemment de phénomène qui
arrivrive tard et on peut le souhaiter
le plus tard possible dans la vie de
chacun on voit bien que un jeune actif
s'il a 30 35 ans et qu'on lui demande
d'apporter une contribution pour créer
un nouveau droit parce qu'il s'agira
d'un nouveau droit et quand de et que
dans le même temps il a l'impression que
les générations qui elles ont moins
connu le chômage
qu'elles-même ou ce jeune que lui même
s'il a le sentiment ou si ces jeunes
générations ont le sentiment que ceux
qui ont eu des carrières plus continues
moins interrompus moins difficile que
eux ce à quoi ils sont confrontés alors
ces jeunes générations s'interrogeront
sur la légitimité et le bien fondé de
notre protection sociale et donc
j'insiste parce que la question de la
cohérence la question de la cohésion la
question de l'égalité de la contribution
demandée à chacun elle n'est pas
simplement un effort financier ou de
justice financière il ne s'agit pas
seulement il s'agit aussi de dire car
revenu égal la contribution doit être
égale quel que soit l'âge que l'on a et
au fond un retraité qui a une retraite
de 2000 ou 2500 € il
a autant de légitimité ou de nécessité
de contribuer que l'actif qui a un
revenu de 2000 ou 2500 € mais au-delà de
cette exigence me semble-t-il d'équité
financière dès lors encore une fois que
nous parlons de ceux des retraités qui
sont imposables mais au-delà donc de
cette exigence financière il y va de la
solidité de la crédibilité de la
légitimité de notre système de
protection sociale j'insiste un peu
là-dessus parce que il me semble parfois
entendre les jeunes
générations s'interroger sur le devenir
de notre système et avoir voir le
sentiment qu'elles sont du fait de
condition de notre économie de
l'évolution de notre économie qu'elles
sont confrontés à des conditions de vie
à des conditions de travail à des
conditions d'acquisition des droits
sociaux qui sont beaucoup plus difficile
que ça n'a été le cas dans le passé il
ne s'agit pas de stigmatiser les
générations passées tant mieux si la
situation a pu être plus facile et et
meilleure mais pour pour autant il nous
faut entendre que la solidarité entre
les générations elle passe aussi par un
financement
intergénérationnel des droits que nous
voulons construire à
Patricia à Patricia chilinger qui m'a
notamment interrogé sur la question des
retraités agricoles je veux rappeler
qu'en effet ou confirmer qu'en effet le
Gouvernement a souhaité prendre une
mesure immédiate dans ce PLFSS pour
relever le le niveau de retraite des
agriculteurs qui ont dû interrompre leur
activité pour cause d'invalidité ou de
longue maladie pour autant nous
n'oublions pas que d'autres mesures
doivent être prises pardon et elles
seront élaborées l'année prochaine à
l'occasion de la réflexion sur les
retraites dans le cadre d'un groupe de
travail conduit avec le ministre de
l'Agriculture Stéphane Lefol je voudrais
aussi toujours à la suggestion de
Patricia chilinger revenir sur la
situation des chômeurs âgés vous l'avez
dit la suppression de la er a constitué
un moment enfin ou une épreuve pour
beaucoup de nos concitoyens je je je
répète une fois de plus que je suis
parfaitement consciente de ces
difficultés très attentive aux
situations ainsi créées le gouvernement
a permis le retour à la retraite à 60
ans pour une partie des de la population
c'est une première réponse nous devons
prendre le temps d'évaluer ces effets
avant de voir si d'autres solutions né
de la suppression enfin d'autres
évolutions sont nécessaires pour faire
face aux situations nées de la
suppression de
l'AER d'ailleurs
euh ces études sont en cours et c'est
sur la base de ces éléments précis que
nous examinerons que le gouvernement
examinera les réponses envisageables euh
dans son propos Laurence Cohen a salué
le gel de la convergence tarifaire je
tiens à vous préciser madame la
sénatrice qu'il ne s'agit pas simplement
d'un gel mais bel et bien d'une
suppression puisque la convergence est
injuste dans ces principes inéquitable
dans son application et inefficace on
l'a vu dans ses résultats cette
suppression s'inscrit dans la
perspective de la réhabilitation du
service public hospitalier et de la
reconnaissance des missions spécifiques
réalisées par l' hôpital public d'autres
mesures qui figurent d'ailleurs dès ce
PLFSS constittu des réponses vous avez
au-delà d'autres mesures mais vous avez
en particulier regretté que le taux
d'ondâ soit fixé à 2,7 % sans atteindre
3 % c'était un des points importants et
je sais que ce point est important pour
vous vous l'avez indiquer je veux vous
indiquer vous vous vous préciser que
dans le compte texte financier que nous
connaissons nous assumons parfaitement
le gouvernement assume de dire que les
comptes sociaux doivent
participer à la trajectoire de
rétablissement de l'équilibre de nos
comptes public et pour autant la santé
est une priorité puisque ce taux d'ondâ
a été fixé à 2,7 et non pas à 2,5 comme
c'était le cas précédemment non pas pour
accompagner l'évolution des dépenses au
fil de l'eau tel qu'elle se présente
parce que à ce moment-là ça n'est même
pas 2,7 ou 3 c'est bien davantage qu'il
aurait fallu faire mais pour mettre en
place pour investir dans des réformes de
fond qui vont nous permettre à la fois
de mieux répondre aux attentes des
patients et en même temps de constituer
des économies très concrètement si nous
voulons mieux soigner c'est-à-dire
mettre en place des traitement plus
efficace qui soit des traitements sur
les maladies que nous connaissons ou
l'accompagnement du vieillissement nous
devons dégager des marges financières ça
suppose que nous
puissions regarder par ailleurs ce que
sont les économies que nous pouvons
faire il est inenvisageable je le dis de
pouvoir répondre aux besoins nouveaux
sans procéder à une évaluation des
politiques telles qu'elles existent et
qu' qu'elles se sont mises en place je
veux plus généralement vous remercier
Mesdames et Messieurs les parlementaires
les sénateurs sénatrice de la majorité
euh qui ont souligné donc les avancées
de ce PLFSS remercier ainsi Jean-Pierre
planc qui a rappelé que ce texte
s'inscrivait dans une démarche d'équité
et de justice à travers des mesures
comme la mise en place de praticiens
territoriaux de médecine générale le
versement de compléments de mode de
garde euh ou les mesures pour les femmes
en particulier l'IVG je voudrais euh
remercier Aline archambau et Jean des
qui ont parlé d'un PLFSS de rupture et
ont souligné qu'il n'introduisait aucune
remise en cause des prestations tout en
permettant de nouvelles avancées
essentielles vous avez regretté madame
archimau que ce PLFSS ne comporte pas de
mesures plus fortes en faveur de la
santé
environnementale je veux vous rappeler
que nous préparons un projet de loi de
santé publique pour 2013 qui permettra
de donner un élan véritable à un domaine
qui a effectivement été totalement
oublié au cours des dernières années et
qui pour autant a déjà fait l'objet de
mesures de la part de ce gouvernement à
travers des propositions de loi qui ont
pu être évoqué je pense l'interdiction
du bisphénol A par exemple ou à travers
la mise en place dans ce PLFSS de
mesures plus marquées en direction de
stratégie
comportemental dans la poursuite de ce
que la grande conférence
environnementale avait euh
annoncé je voudrais dire à Michel Meier
qui a rappelé euh les avancé
essentielles que ce
PLFSS prévoit pour les familles qu'il
est en effet important de conforter de
consolider le rôle de l'ensemble des
familles dans notre société de ne pas en
avoir une vision abstraite mais bien de
faire en sorte que toutes les familles y
compris les plus modestes euh soitent à
même d'exercer leur rôle et je vous
remercie d'avoir en particulier rappelé
l'expérimentation du tiers payant pour
les gardes d'enfants euh le congé et le
congé d'accueil de l'enfant sur la
branche ATMP Jacquy lemain a détaillé
des mesures de justice présente dans ce
texte il a aussi exprimé vous avez
monsieur le sénateur exprimé votre
préoccupation sur le niveau de la
sinistralité et sur la dette cumulée de
la branche sur le niveau de la
sinistralité ce sera l'un des enjeux
majeurs de la convention d'objectif et
de gestion qui sera discuté l'an
prochain et qui s'attachera à renforcer
les dispositifs de protection sur la
dette le gouvernement a adopté dans
cette période de crise une approche
équilibrée avec une croissance modérée
des cotisations patronales qui permet
d'enrayer l'accumulation de la dette de
cette branche je voudrais dire à
Jean-Étienne
Antoinette que le gouvernement prend
parfaitement en compte les spécificités
de l'outreem dans le financement de
l'hôpital et je veux dire que la réforme
de la tarification à l'activité qui est
engagée devra naturellement mieux
intégrer enfin donc il y a un groupe de
travail qui s'appelle transparence et
qualité qui s'est mis qui se metta en
place et que donc cette réforme devra
naturellement mieux intégrer des surcûts
spécifiques liés à l'isolement et aux
spécificités de certaines activités
hospitalières outremèr enfin Jean-Luc
ficher je euh voudrais indiquer que je
le remercie d'avoir mis l'accent dans
son intervention sur l'accès aux soins
il a effectivement indiqué ma volonté de
présenter prochainement des mesures
globales incitatives euh
d'accompagnement de l'installation de
professionnels de santé médecins mais
pas uniquement médecins d'ailleurs il
faut le dire dans des territoires qui
aujourd'hui apparaissent souvent
injustement peu attractif mais qui de
fait connaissent une certaine
désertification et et c'est pour nous
pour tous les élus locaux mais pour nous
gouvernement un enjeu
important donc je procéderai à des ces
annonces dans dans quelques semaines il
a marqué sa préoccupation ou sa volonté
que soit reconnu
euh les comment dire l'activité
d'herboriste des les activités
d'herboristerie je crois que vous serez
enfin je crois savoir que vous serez
prochainement reçu à mon cabinet pour
évoquer ces questions-là je ne doute pas
que
euh une place puisse être reconnu à ces
activités je tiens moins à dire que pour
euh des pathologies vous avez évoqué des
pathologies grave il ne faut pas
introduire de confusion dans l'esprit
des patients madames et Messieurs je
vous
remercie merci madame la ministre nous
passons donc à la discussion des euh
articles et à l'article 1er j'ai une
demande de prise de parole de madame
Isabelle
Pasquet merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers
collègues euh comme chaque année
euh avec cet article premier nous
revenons sur les prévisions de recet et
de dépenses du régime général
obligatoire de base tel qu'issue des
travaux du Parlement exci important qui
nous donne l'occasion d'analyser à
postériori l'exactitude des estimations
voire même leur
sincérité cette année l'exercice est
particulièrement intéressant puisqu'en
dépit d'une estimation de croissance
abusivement volontariste l'examen des
tableaux d'équilibre de l'exercice 2011
se rélève meilleur que ce qui était
initialement prévu dans le projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
pour
2011 ainsi le résultat définitif pour
2011 fait apparaître un déficite 19,1
milliards d'euros contre les 22,4
milliards prévus dans le PLFSS pour
2011 le premier constat que nous voulons
formuler que cet article fait la
démonstration que ce dont souffre la
sécurité sociale c'est d'abord et avant
tout d'un manque de recette comment ne
pas faire le lien entre la moindre
dégradation des comptes sociaux en 2011
et le fait que la progression d'un mass
salariale est été meilleure que celle
prévue cette progression a rapporté à
elle seul 1,5 milliard d'euros de
cotisation supplémentaire démonstration
est faite que l'apport de recette
nouvelle à destination de la protection
sociale constitue le levier le plus fort
pour remédier à la dégradation continue
des comptes sociaux ainsi la hausse des
prélèvements sociaux sur les revenus du
capital a contribué à réduire la dette
sociale on voit bien que la recherche de
financement de la sécurité sociale du
côté du capital constitue une piste
qu'il faut porter jusqu'au bout
c'est-à-dire jusqu'à ce que celui-ci
soit soumis au même prè manque le
travail il n'y a en effet aucune raison
pour que les milliards qui servent à la
spéculation qui échappent à la
rémunération du travail voire qui
participe à la destruction de l'emploi
ne soit pas soumis à cotisation
sociale pour autant nous ne nous
satisfaisons pas que dans le même temps
les ménages c'est-à-dire les salariés é
été pour leur part soumis à de nouveaux
prélèvement injuste emputant leur
pouvoir d'achat et disant cela je pense
par particulièrement au doublement de la
taxe sur les contrats mutualistes dit
complémentaires cette mesure fiscale est
prise en dépit du bon sens puisqu'elle
pénalise en fait des contrats don le
principe repose sur une réduction du
reste à charge supporté par les patients
qui respecteraient un parcours de soins
censé limiter les dépenses supportées
par la Sécurité sociale au final ce
doublement de la taxe se traduit par une
augmentation du prix de ces contrats et
parmi les plus modestes certains de nos
concitoyens se résolent à réduire la
formule de leur complémentaire et ainsi
à réduire le montant de leur prise en
charge d'autres renoncent au contrat
responsable ce qui indu des dépenses
supplémentaires pour la sécurité sociale
et enfin d'autres encore vont jusqu'à
renoncer à souscrire une mutuelle avec
les conséquences les conséquences que
l'on connaît sur la santé et
particulièrement sur la sur la
prévention c'est d'ailleurs la raison
pour laquelle nous continuons à demander
vous le savez la suppression de cette
mesure nous mesurons à quel point la
politique des gouvernements précédents
qui n'a consisté qu'à réduire les
dépenses sociales tout en restant très
timide sur la recherche de recettes
nouvelles a eu d'importantes
conséquences pour les assurés sociaux
ainsi la partie de cet article relatif à
longondam pour 2011 enregistre une
moindre dépense qui s'élève à
166,3 milliards d'euros contre les 167,1
milliards d'euros prévus par la loi de
financement pour 2011 or nous ne savons
que trop que ce qu'il est courant
d'appeler la maîtrise de long dam
résulte à la fois de l'application
stricte de la convergence tarifaire et
du gel en début d'année des dotations
allouées au titre d'mission d'intérêt
général ce mécanisme sur lequel entend
revenir le gouvernement pénalise
lourdement les établissements publics de
santé qui supportent seul les efforts de
réduction des dépenses hospitalières
alors que les cliniques commerciales
participent à les
accroître enfin nous constatons
également que la moindre dégradation de
la cadèe n'est pas le fruit d'un apport
nouveau de recette il s'agit en réalité
pour 2011 du moins à une réduction du
taux des crédits appliqué à la cadèe par
les marchés financiers non pas comme
nous avons pu le constater à la suite de
l'élection présidentielle parce que les
opérateurs présents sur les marchés
internationaux ont baissé leur taux
démontrant ainsi qu'il faisait plus
confiance à la gauche qu'à la droite
pour zorber la dette sociale mais parce
que la cadette à refinancer à moyen et
long terme des emprunts contractés à
court terme le taux des emprunts à long
terme étant inférieur à celui des
empruns à court terme cela explique le
ralentissement de la dégradation des
comptes de la cadèe la situation est
loin pour autant d'être satisfaisante
puisque ce faisant le coût total des
charges de crédit supporté par la cadè
dans la durée va mécaniquement
s'accroître pour toutes ces raisons et
parce que la situation des Comptes pour
2011 résulte d'un manque de volonté isme
quant à l'apport de ressources
complémentairire à la scurité sociale et
assise sur une base juste et solidaire
le groupe CRC s'abstendra sur cet
article merci Madame Pasquet est-ce
qu'il y a d'autres demandes de prise de
parole sur l'article
1er je n'en vois pas je vais donc mettre
au voie l'article 1er quels sont ceux
qui sont pour son
adoption avis
contraire
abstention il est adopté nous quittons
l'hémicycle du Sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance très belle
journée à
tous